bad i at least say discord wait dokey i'm actually live
you're really a active white dude with like gelled up hair
that sounds british yeah that's me oh yeah we've been to
that okay she looks like lemon from uh bullet train yeah
yeah damn you're saying the black dude also you're saying
everybody before i start before i start thank you to post
your blind spot for the sponsor um we have because sure for
is missing yes we don't know where he is oh no he is missing
right now and we are you don't know where he is he has
disappeared uh he has disappeared from society we have
called him better than the japanese version we have called
Uh, we don't know where he is.
But yeah, check out PUBG blind spot while we figure this
out.
Oh, Japanese is so much better.
I think the Japanese version, she's too quiet.
She lacks huge.
There's no sauce in her voice.
I need the sauce.
But it, but it gives like, it gives like a sense of like of
Clarency and kind of like the like of herself and gives like
a more emotion because she's not a loud person.
so when you okay sorry i'm just like listening so we are
trying to she feels like she's not taking that same emotion
like she's in the japanese i sound like such a weak right
now we are trying to figure out what to do right now and
trying to find us up we at one point we were like do we just
grab a random chat member like does anyone in chat have
played the game what's your defense you might have a chance
to play with us the linking sounds of the dad makes when he
becomes a or we pull a random chat member that's all you
were talking about okay whatever and uh no but also why cry
no in the movie so anytime she opened her mouth i would just
start crying maybe it's because i'm a father now if you
don't have experience we can't play with you she went
through all of those trials and tribulations just to save
her parents from touching so we need we can either go one or
two ways because i watched like the first part of the
japanese version i was like wow is she not saucing her voice
like why is she anyway oh my god he went to bed at six in
the morning no no i i do get the i do get the cool sort of
artistic angle of her not being a professional actor which
actually gives a lot more yes i just feel it gives a lot
more realism to the role i get it guys i just noticed sure
for went to bed at six in the morning i i have no idea i
think he's at yeah he might have been in bed at six or seven
in the morning
well reset the clock anyway guys feel free to scan the qr
code you're like a really super good player i just realized
that I didn't know who you were.
Oh, you're really good at video games.
Oh, no, I'm pretty mad.
No, no, no, I'm pretty mad.
All right, all right.
So you're going to have to carry us.
You're going to have to carry all of us.
You're the guy with over 3,000 hours in season.
That is true.
You have like a huge brain compared to me.
Wait.
Okay, but hold up.
You are wearing a jersey in your photo.
Oh, I think that trumps any kind of playtime.
Don't look at that photo.
No, no, no, no, no, don't, don't, don't.
I'm not bald, by the way.
I'm not bald.
wait sure for sure for the wake he said he was like wait i
thought it was p.m pst and i was like no bro it's i said 6 p
.m esd i said six esd bro i don't know if he's home though i
don't know he's gonna be really mentally prepared i'm sure
yeah yeah he's definitely gonna be very awake Thatcher, I
played Siege for like 50 hours and I was trying to learn the
game in and out.
I get, and then I go straight into ranked and I'm getting
rolled by gold players.
And you're telling me, you're telling me that you don't have
a bigger brain than me.
You're telling me that.
But I haven't played Siege in a while.
Yeah, but your, your experience doesn't go.
It's like riding a bicycle though.
Yeah, true.
It doesn't go.
All transfers, I guess.
Like it's just, you just have the, like I'm expecting you to
carry the shit out of me.
in this but i don't have like i don't know what half of
these champions do it'll take me like a death or two to
understand what each dude is doing exactly you're smart as
you got two two deaths that's it you're going you're coming
in as hot blazing like immediately i think i can do it i'll
just stick with this one guy and i'll get really good at him
all right all right oh my god sure force here oh my god
you're awake yo sure for you're right on time oh my god
thank you babe yay i even have called you call you i even or
how what time did you go to bed good morning that's where i
looked at some documents and like atheist yeah like eight
like as in as in like 6 p.m es eastern time
what time do you have to ask you to yeah take one for the
team and boost this server with good bandwidth because i
feel like every 10 seconds since I get hit with a 270 ping
on this discord server and you guys sound like robots oh I
mean we can ask we can ask them to use pubg money for it
they're pubg delirium pink gems where are your pink gems
truly outrageous oh yeah I need a
oh anyway let's talk because we got to get dokey bird in
because donkey bird's channel We've hijacked.
She's in here, though.
That's me.
It's gonna be one of our first interviews.
Welcome in.
Hello.
Hello, hello.
How are you?
How's things?
I see you've been grinding the game.
Well, we almost had a little emergency because SureFour
wasn't awake, so we were like, what do we do?
So we're like, how about we pull a random chat member?
We were like, all right, let's pull a random chat member and
like whoever has PUBG Blast Black Spirits, come right in.
And then, but then now he's here.
So we're fine.
We're not 4v5ing.
So everything's great.
do you know what that would have been quite fun i must admit
but to be fair phalanx here would have been like let me sub
me and get me out of the cast this year he's been playing
quite well so so you're back to a five let's let's talk
about the team though obviously you guys been having a bit
of practice so how you find in the game obviously is out now
um who's your go-to character who's the agent that you kind
of i don't know i think her name is claris right yeah oh yes
yeah yeah so amazing my friends yeah one of my friends was
like she's the easiest character i'm like that's
I must admit, I'm going to hold my hands up.
I like her as well.
I like the motion detection.
I like to be able to kind of throw those sensors out and
watch those players come in.
So I think a critical player.
I think a critical player.
And for Alex, I'll hand over to you, mate, because I know
it's a character you like to play as well.
I mean, you just answered the most important question,
right?
And we seem to be very well aligned in the way we like to
play our characters.
Good thing about Clarice also is you never run out of
bullets.
You just never get it reloaded.
Any other things you're doing about it.
Is this similar to any of the games you've played before?
Any touch-ups, anything's regarding the general structure of
the game?
Because a lot of people keep referring to some other games,
but I still feel like it has its unique take.
Well, I think the difference is that it's top-down, so a lot
of stuff, there's a lot of new angles and stuff to look into
and stuff.
And there's the util being matched to each agent, so it
really depends on the certain play styles you want to go
for.
Are you more like a lurker?
Or are you more like a campy-type style and stuff like that?
where like all your vision is shared with your entire team
too which adds into the whole like teamwork thing where
maybe the lurker sees them and then the people who are on
site can come out and help the lurker as well because they
have the same sites as well so that's like the new stuff to
be aware of definitely some really new mechanics as well
yeah final final one for us final one for us before we let
you go because you know you need to get ready right yeah
what game style is this team going to bring and more
importantly who should be watching are you an aggressive
team are you going to be campy stuff what are we expecting
though from this team i have honestly i have no idea i like
we'll see how it goes we're trying to honestly we're going
to figure out our style live on on like in our first match
well don't you look obviously it's been a pleasure coming in
obviously this is day number one first and foremost though
best of luck for the team i like that get this creativity uh
on the spot so again best luck i let you guys get ready
we've got a couple other teams that we need to get through
um i'm not even gonna ask you you're expected to win right
because this is your crate that's pretty awkward i got
knocked out on my own own tournament i i don't even show up
for day two i just look you gotta bring it you gotta bring
it you got five up so yeah that's true we just did win one
we just did win one that's all we need to win we're getting
more than one we're getting more one we're here to support
you don't believe we'd like the character we believe we
believe much love yeah yeah calling fouls be like oh we
gotta eliminate someone on the other team it looks like they
they they messed up there gotta make it up 45 oh what points
for jokie bird i believe no we're believers we are believers
best luck again though we'll see you in a bit and obviously
see you around number one yeah thank you thank you so much
bye i believe my okay i'm back i just cursed on doki stream
oh wait oh did i i don't even know i got pulled into the
interview what the are you talking about yeah she was
talking about how much you like sure for i heard the whole
thing he was great yeah yeah i was gonna be like everybody
was on time i can't wait all right sure for what are you
what character are you playing we're
going to do great guys i believe it all right i picked a
white guy by the way are they like wait but like there's
multiple white guys in there which one is it no but i mean
like well you're thinking of white skin oh yeah yes no i'm
talking about the guy that was wearing a white shirt oh
you're thinking about skin i was talking about the guy that
was wearing the white shirt no no goldberg has a white
jacket and a white white mask yeah and wilson Whistle has
white hair and I'm pretty sure a full-blown cloak trumps you
here and his whole face is white.
Yeah, but his other, the rest of his outfit is black.
Half of his outfit is black if you think about it.
No, but from the... Alright, I'm gonna leave this up to you.
I don't know if I'm the right person to make this call, but
I'm playing Goldberg.
Alright, wait, we have a room already.
Oh, his special ability is white too.
Which one?
No, I actually have a real issue with this sometimes, Doki,
because sometimes in video games you have thermal scopes and
sometimes the background is white and everybody's black.
And sometimes the background is black and everybody's white.
And you have to be like, what do you get?
And what happens after that?
Thermal scopes you like more.
And it's like, uh, you better answer that question.
I'm making coffee while I wait for him to get in the lobby.
All right.
We're okay.
We can join the lobby now.
How the fuck do you?
Oh, there it is.
I was last here first in the lobby.
Oh, shit.
I got dragged in.
okay so custom game custom game and then put in that code oh
okay yeah that code that's in the chat i low-key forgot i
even had the game all right all right uh sound guy put
badger down a little bit let me know if it's better we're
still locked in guys that's because i was putting that's how
if you can remember your six digit code when when you have
to verify anything yeah your your brain's good don't worry
your brain is all good all right all team did you just click
plus on the attack team like that's on you dude no i joined
in it threw me in there guys i believe i believe in this i
believe in us we we just need to win one game and then we
make it to day two that's all i even practiced a little bit
i even practiced guys we just need to win one no one day one
game sorry
all right we're so ready
okay who's seen those pro siege players that literally sit
like eight millimeters away from on their screen what the i
feel like what the and they got their keyboards curved like
crabs i don't like cs players are also like that too they so
i saw one where like someone just taped a magnifying glass
on the crosshair
this bio 4k monitor dog just break up with 1080p what's
wrong you bro yeah but 1080p is like nice you know it's kind
of like the the go-to it feels the good the watch and look
at now you're not familiar with the gilded resolution 2k
1440p was it was that hashtag ad i couldn't tell i'm sorry
do you have a code for it do you have a you have a code for
it no hardware manufacturer will sponsor me so no why what
did you do okay i gotcha when truthfully i know nothing
about high level play in video games so you're probably
right no you again you got like 4 000 hours you got you got
the dumbest thing you can think possible yeah we do want to
support the game like i know the game really well but i also
played it um but here's the thing when you don't play the
game properly way more than anyone when you play the game
more like out of anyone and you know how to like manipulate
the mindset of a player then that technically makes you a
very smart player compared to the normal average person
because they're so sheepbrained when it comes to playing one
game yeah so you you they only know how to play one way and
you innovate it and then you make it really uh different and
then they don't know what to do and that shows that you're
smarter it's just I'm very in that's why okay I see it
that's why with your 5 000 hours you know how to play the
game I'm just gonna listen am I am I allowed to I'm just
right i'm just gonna listen to just gotta listen that's okay
i don't feel like i'm that good at siege because i watched
siege like over the long time ago but i i still think all
the neurons are still there i'll be okay i believe i know i
upped up heavenly oh yeah jinks he's the greatest but he's
not even siege anymore he's more of a clash of clans guy
right clash that's where he's every time and he's not a
siege guy anymore whatever it is is he a rocket league guy
now kind of he kind of like reinvents himself a lot and he
goes to like different games and just revitalizes each game
for a couple of months this guy's on rocket league yeah i
was just he was on rocket league early he did this whole
thing where he's like oh my god this is like a thumb right
now wait he's a he has no eyebrows and no hair yeah he
shaved up his eyebrows that it would regrow and tune it
because i think he's in his three weeks it's like three to
four months so Oh, wait, that takes like two, that takes
like over two months.
Yeah, what if he's just born different?
No, I, oh yeah, born different.
He's not going to grow his hair back.
You don't know that.
Look at him.
Look at him right now.
Pull up his Twitch.
He told me that's going to grow back.
Does he ever have hair?
I thought he's always bald.
Wasn't he, yeah, he has like very little hair.
But is that choice or just genetic?
do you know do you know in the vine days the the guy that
says web is is like he looks like that so he looks like that
guy surely right i feel like i feel like i'm not i'm not
like exaggerating right i didn't even check up the games i'm
so out of it bro no they're doing interviews right now so
like we still like a ton of no i'm gonna kill man see you in
two hours I'm here to shoot people and talk shit in their
chats afterwards.
Unless they win, which case I won't.
Yeah, what do we do?
What do we do if they win?
I'd just be like, I wasn't even playing.
That's right.
I was checking the rules this year.
If I can trash talk and all chat during.
Wait, so can you?
That's probably okay.
Yeah, that's probably being a little toxic.
It's just a little friendly banter.
I held my own team.
Without crossing the line, Heavenly, you can't say you want
to blow up.
somebody's house or something i know okay i want kernel
level access to your pc yeah i don't see nothing into this
is i can't technically you can say it just you have to say
in game ask for forgiveness not permission that's what they
say aru hodo naru hodo naru hodo
I can't wait to repeat that phrase from the inside of a jail
cell.
Please.
Why would you be in a jail cell?
I missed my taxes one year.
Because I didn't ask permission to go on to the military
base.
You know what I'm saying?
Why are you going on the military base?
I got bored.
I wanted to fly a plane.
I played enough.
I wanted to see the funny helicopters.
I've played enough GTA I know how to fly a helicopter.
You just go up and then forward.
Simple.
And how many helicopters have you crashed gta yeah then you
get against the the flying bike and then you get shot out of
the air by someone with it with a controller aim body you
across the map only time i ever played gta and i was like oh
this game is ass and i was like the only time you don't have
experience flying helicopters and i was like nah
oh they're ready to start apparently everyone ready to run
the set yeah let's go i think it's like what first to five
points right or first to four points or five points i don't
remember four points all right four points is not yeah all
right first to four points we play it well we get three
defense points all right i don't feel that i'm level nine
everyone's one and level four and low five and then there's
a there's someone that's level 25.
don't worry about that we combine all our levels together
we're still Oh, that is true.
That is true.
I didn't do that, but you could have done.
Yeah, yeah, but Surefort definitely did that, right?
You definitely are smurfing right now.
I just got back.
What did I do?
Yeah, you're on your smurf account, right?
That's why you're level one.
Oh.
I have like three team death matches.
Did you even play a real game?
Did you?
No.
Okay, we're so locked.
We're so locked.
I've only played the tutorial.
do the tutorial we're yeah yeah yeah yeah you're right
you're right you're right we're learning live that's true
that's true we're showing everyone how easy it is to pick up
the game how how fun and easy it is
yeah i'm gonna say that about rainbow six siege when there's
like 87 operators now no you'll get it just die hundreds of
times you play it no you just gotta hit your head against
the eventually the wall will break yes that's good advice
yeah oh like we'll be fine guys all right rival's heads is
dead cool even fun we'll be fine i can answer this one yes i
can't i didn't play that game in like a year and a half okay
first off i don't think no no actually no probably you have
not been playing no you didn't play it since last year i
think yeah year and a half is it no no that's no you're
fucking my brain now hold on two years yeah even longer no
there's no way it's two years rivals just had his one year
anniversary there's no way 92 years okay you're fucking with
me i'm like zoning out in and out of this conversation and
now i'm just completely
It sounds like you're building a wonder in Age of Empires.
No, he's speaking backwards.
I was going backwards in time.
Trying to recount everything.
He's casting a spell on you.
Go back in time.
I love it.
Oh, damn.
You got fans in chat, Super Gomez.
Is that my goat, Super Gomez?
Why are you seeing this?
I do not believe this.
Doki's chat and the person's name is Tana Kaoki.
Kanahoki.
Shouts out to you for recognizing me when I'm a lame chud.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
I appreciate it a lot.
Wait, is he said Doki's shot or the blind spot shot?
My main broadcast up on Twitch.
They're using my Twitch.
Oh, they can't even hear me.
What's the point of saying that?
I can't even hear you.
Then they can clip that.
You can clip that and send it over to them.
Don't do that.
Oh, I'm going to personally DM them on Twitch.
here's my reaction give me a follow thank you there now
everybody's shouting you out look yeah yeah oh look is it
goat mez goat mez i don't believe you i'm pulling up your
twitch hold on pull it up you think i would just lie look
there's hi super gomez from dokey's youtube stream we can
hear you look at that hey guys i'm a fat chud hey guys
what's going on don't expect much from me uh shout out to
good sam 92 thank you hey can someone gift a gifted sub
right now please right now i need it i mean she needs it
sorry not sorry she needs it not me please please i know oh
i feel so stupid i'm like talking to a funny wall
oh no someone says hi hi badger oh someone recognized you oh
cherry berry but he's still interviewing wait the interview
is done yeah they're still interviewing no the guy's gone
from the interview chat oh no see I knew it we're in let's
go let's go oh with the Sigma all right I caught dibs on
Claris she's the only character I know how to play all right
I'm picking Claris as fast as I can no you are not you are
not I am not getting knocked out on my own tournament sure
for has got this all right sure for might be better than
dokey because i know that he plays he plays professionally
why is my character oh yeah some characters aren't on
defense that's a big thing oh yeah we forgot to mention that
you got your patch i guess i'll pick molotov cocktail man
all right now i know the clearest is so i can take it what
hold on sorry oh my god what the fuck were you doing i'm
trying to make sure i don't get this wrong you're talking to
la gladiators The man who sniped and killed two people in
spawn in the beginning of the game.
You're talking to the man himself.
It's LA.
It's LA Gladiators, Kings Row, Widowmaker, Nature for
Roberts.
Press F.
Okay, yeah, sorry.
You had your own credentials on the right.
Sorry.
I think he would remember his own credentials.
I shall put it here.
Wait, this map is so big.
I keep running.
Where am I?
Oh, wait.
They're not gonna breach!
Do I have bargain?
Come in!
I'm across the fucking map.
They're gonna fucking come in!
Wait, I could see outside for a split second.
Why are you outside?
I'm not outside, I'm inside.
Okay, okay, it's fine.
I got motion.
I have no idea where...
Okay, I'm ready to shoot whoever is over here.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, do you see that?
My motion.
Sensor detected.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're here.
Where am I?
Whoever comes over here, I'm blasting them.
Guys, there's...
Wait, why is there an entire map over here and there's only
two sites over there?
Oh, I know.
The sites are dynamic?
I told them I was going to fry them.
They thought she was asleep, bro.
I'm looking at this corner.
I'm going to flank them.
I got one.
They're all there, by the way.
Oh my god, they had it on the ruddy.
god you got killed nice told them it was not i don't know
why they thought embarrassing oh there's still one more over
there all right i got the whole point on cover we can just
flank i'll flank hold on i got another last one last one who
wants to kill the last one i'm going around the corner i got
this one i'm a maywall i mean i'm spamming okay that's i'm
going in i'm entering oh yeah we did it oh my god yeah
what's with this foam oh that's just it's just a lot button
in this game keyboard settings i don't think so i think we
no i swear there was because i know that's right it was push
to talk because i know there is you have there is i've seen
it i've seen people use emojis on me dude i can't find it
because i'm ready to talk oh just go into your controls oh i
can change my thing from the razor wire yeah yep see this is
where i was earlier where the were you this is the same dude
you could just walk across the map look how do i draw my
razor wire how do i drop my right oh dude i could just run
across the map this place is so big i was like what the heck
we have to defend this whole place there's only two bomb
sites over here yeah so then they just i have an idea choose
did they choose which angle they're attacking yeah yeah they
get to choose where to drop nobody okay they're over here
okay i'm throwing a wall a motion sensor and another one
here i knew they were gonna try that oh wait you're you're
detected well i'm using your motion sensor to see when they
when they peek me that's their motion sensor that's not oh
wait that's yeah no yours is the one in the corner okay
that's good to know are they with you wait i'm cooked where
am i you're like stuck in a corner i don't know how you're
gonna get out of here you'll imagine there's one outside i'm
about to pop out oh shit no pick me up wait Don't pick me
up.
Don't pick me up.
Keep it.
Are you guys okay over there?
Okay.
He gets me blue.
I don't want to jump here.
Okay.
You gotta do it again.
Yeah, go.
Hey, you hop through.
Oh my god.
They're throwing it in.
Oh, that will kill you.
That will kill you!
Yeah, we got to walk back.
We gotta come back.
What the frick is that?
It's like a little.
Okay, I got one.
I got another I don't like my character's gun the best part
Wait what There's one over here I'm done Wait where's the
last guy One enemy left Oh I couldn't get Pichu Pichu's on
my axe Ace Alright go there you go We're fine See we're fine
We're fine Why does my vector only have 20 bullets This
thing's got 1200 RP for 12.
Yeah, bro.
Every shot matters.
It's like 0.1 seconds.
Yeah, so you just got to hit every shot.
There's no problem.
Come on, sure.
This thing's supposed to be for suppressive fire.
1200 rounds, 24.
We are suppressing this dog.
Where's my fucking drum mag, man?
You don't get one, babes.
You got to make every bullet in there.
You have a second gun.
Just pull out your second gun.
Oh, wait, no, I don't have infinite ammo.
No, you don't.
You don't.
I'm shooting this shit down range, man.
suppressing fire wait for i have an idea someone threw a
freaking small expanding circle that ate me yeah i have a
gas you want you you can kill them through it when they come
out of this door over here you not want to they think
they're gonna come out of this door which okay so this one
over here okay oh my god i have to i'm gonna put i'm gonna
put this wall here you want me to wide pink it yeah go go in
there oh hold on i mean body blocking yeah yeah all right
good luck surely they're gonna push over here he full boxed
me by you oh there you go i see how bad you're in that room
just watch that room i'm covering b right if you hit c and
crowd they're throwing oh wait they're changing their attack
they're here gas round fired you saw one budger hold on i
got one directly ahead of me in that room heavily there is
friendly fire there is friendly fire guys no hold on i have
a huge like angle on them You might want to back on Badger.
There's another in there.
It would be a shame that Gomez ran.
Don't worry.
Oh my God, they're all here.
Oh my God.
Yeah, they are.
I got you.
Hold on.
Yo, check it out.
Check the bomb.
Watch this.
Dang.
Yo, check this one.
Dude, I got another one.
I don't know how my impact needs.
Oh, it's through the road.
Oh my God.
It's fine.
Who was just telling me they got motion?
That's that.
Me, boy.
I'm out here to change motion.
All right, all right, oh, Pete, go.
Go, go, go, go.
Remember the trick?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
The shield, the shield try.
Hold on.
Yeah, yeah.
So the shields in this game work like my other shield guy
and other shield things.
So if I have the shield and put it up and you plant, they
can't shoot around it.
Yeah.
So what's going to happen?
I'm going to put a big ass wall while he engages first.
And then we just plant it.
We're going to go.
Main entrance.
We can just rush in by me.
We can go run.
Right here.
the thing oh yeah if you press alt and left click you can
put oh wait no it's right click can we go for here the pawn
spawns no no no it's random
there's an entire right side of the building don't worry
about that no way there's so much real estate over there and
we're confined over here everybody don't worry about it
that's like no way about it we got the bomb okay go get who
has the bomb and i'm on the other side of the map oh they
got busted open yeah you'll bust it open it's on the other
side of the map wait wait wait i have an idea i've been
there get in there so break that break that oh my god yeah
molotov there's a maltop that's a maltop oh i'm gonna go to
the sheriff i'm scared you don't have any explosives we
can't break it yeah i have a grenade i can shoot it hold on
you shoot it oh i have a grenade oh there's a guy over there
actually through yeah you can you're his wall bangs i'm
trying to wall bang them he's trying to wall bang us okay
okay hold on we're ready but there's a there's a oh there's
a guy here oh i'm coming over coming over oh i'm gonna put a
big ass a big ass wall they're inside they're in that little
corner they're in the little corner yeah right there just
push them in just push them right there there's a guy right
here there's a guy right here there's guys scanning oh no
there's three people oh my god he crouched they crouched
wait i almost wall banged them You have a grenade to report.
It's up to you.
I will bang them.
You can throw your grenade over the wall.
Oh, never.
I died around a corner, man.
Yeah.
Hold on to that.
I think somebody saw you in that person had a gun, so they
shot you.
Okay.
That was around the corner.
I got a better idea, bro.
I'm going sniper.
Y'all have fun.
I'm just going to be long-ranging them.
That entire round, I just tried the frickin wall bang.
I didn't care about anything else.
You're just like...
Alright, who's picking up the...
I'm gonna...
Yeah.
I have, I have an idea.
So, that whole other house that's over there, I'm just gonna
go through that.
Okay?
You're gonna go through the entire house.
I'm going through the entire house.
I'm gonna look at the scenery.
That is a long walk.
I'm gonna make my way there.
No, it's the long run.
It's how you...
You make them...
I made that run.
It's a long run.
Oh, you did it?
Oh, I didn't even notice.
It's like he was...
Wait.
When we were our first defense, I ran to the opposite side
of the map.
I'm like, guys, this place is so big.
Where is everyone?
Bro, why, bro?
How's exploring?
He wanted to know, he wanted Matt's knowledge, you know?
That doesn't break the barricade in one shot.
Crazy.
Where are we at?
Okay.
On the side of the map.
I'm on my way through the house.
So I do have the guns, the bombs, so.
That's fine.
We all have guns, Doki.
Yeah, but my gun's better.
Hi.
Oh, there's a guy over here.
There's a guy over here.
Nice.
Got one.
Good kill team.
Don't worry, I'm still making my flank.
Is that a camera?
Yeah.
Stop telling me you got motion, dog.
I know you got motion.
I got motion.
I want a motion sensor.
Hold on.
My motion sensor sees motion.
Can you kill motion sensors?
They're one in there.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I'm dead.
Cover me.
Foam wall.
Now.
No, shortboard.
Don't around.
Yeah.
You let him kill me.
The bomb.
I'm on the other side.
Yeah.
Just walk around, bro.
They're all over there.
Yeah.
I may have walled you off on accident.
I couldn't go past anywhere.
That guy is out.
That's got to get a kill.
Oh, you got it.
Never mind.
Here you go.
That is.
behind behind you what the fuck we just need to win if we
win this round we win like we just got to win oh my gosh
it's literally one v2 all right just crouch just crouch just
crouch hit see you guys i don't think we're coordinated in
attack guys i no no we are it's me i'm i'm messing around
they're like over here over there okay if you stand you can
see them if you stand they're gonna Oh, oh, oh, oh, you are
so low, though.
You've got the bomb.
Guys, 30 seconds, 30 seconds, Trifor.
You're just going to solve.
Trifor, Trifor, your bomb.
No, the bomb.
Go, go.
I'm going to kill him.
Okay.
Yeah, we lost.
Oh, Jenga!
It doesn't matter.
Oh, good try.
Health advantage.
Good try.
All right, yo, I got, I have an actual plan this time.
I got a plan this time.
It's a legit plan, all right.
Okay, okay.
I think this map is T-side.
All right, all right.
Let me pick my agent and then we get the starting point.
okay so they keep so we're going to do the same thing we did
the first time just without the shield all right hear me out
okay this is good this is good point guy uh-huh all right
once it once it lets me see we're responding i don't know
why it's taken from it i think it's the same area i'm pretty
sure i think it's the same area every time yeah we get to
pick wherever yeah yeah yeah i know i want to i want to draw
on the map okay okay i'm gonna go all i'm gonna go right
here and make a loud noise right okay y'all just come the
other way they're not gonna they're not gonna I go main
entrance.
I just make big bombs blow shit up take as much noise What
if you die for you?
Okay, okay, okay, you won't I'm playing snake holy fuck I'm
snaking my way through the building They don't put a ping
cool down.
That's awesome This is awesome That's pretty okay, we
spawned me all the way over here.
Oh, no, you didn't pick a spawn, but you know what you're
with me now you're with me boss I'm with you.
All right.
Check this out.
My character has these.
He's got charges right out.
30s.
I hit it.
Motion detector.
We gotta wait for the fire.
Wait for the fire.
Yeah, I have a motion detector on though.
All right.
I'll do it again.
There's one on the wall.
Scanned.
All right.
I got motion.
I placed another motion.
See?
I got their attention.
They're just shooting.
Nothing's even there.
Once again, they're just...
You can't go past because we got them.
Molotov doubt.
Yeah, we got Molotovs.
Yeah, yeah, so I'm waiting.
Full scan that person.
Someone in the corner.
I see it.
Oh my god, there's more Molotovs.
Oh yeah, I can't shoot.
I can't shoot through that.
There's a fence.
There's a wire there, so you get slowed.
Oh, hard right.
Oh, hard right on the site.
Yeah, I know.
How do I break through this?
Yeah, on the other side of the wall, you're on right now.
Hugging that wall, Doki, there's a person in that room.
Yeah.
Got one.
Nice.
There's someone in the back of this room.
I can't get in there is the problem.
I'm going to you, Gomez.
Let me know if I can't plant there.
Can I plant there?
Yeah, yeah, you can.
Oh, I'm planning.
Super Gomez, you saw somebody in the room to your left.
Do it, do it.
I'm planning.
Cover me.
And one behind the a guitar case on a huge angle huge oh
hold on docky i'm gonna come back here okay okay lily peach
who's one in there where i died oh it's all it's all covered
they're not going to think about this this other oh okay all
right there uh yeah dokey there's one right on the a side
they're behind you they're all there's yeah i can't oh i
think we got played together how am i supposed to kill
reinforced walls you you're supposed to use a Yeah.
I don't have one of those.
I know.
I'll say they use.
All right.
So we have defense now, but this is game match point.
I'm ready.
We're defense sided guys.
Green three.
Guys, I think our weakness is we are definitely we don't
play as a team.
I'm.
Bro, I don't see the issue, bro.
I'm like.
Okay.
we just have to win our ones yeah i'm winning all my ones i
even wanted to i lost my one i lost my one i was it was a
1v3 this was a 1v3 player not like 1v5ing why i had to deal
with a 1v3 situation i woke up i won my 1v3 what you talking
about you did not win a 1v3 there is no way yes i did in
matter of fact let me get that skin off you buddy
Wait, I have the wrong utility.
I wanted to do the barbed wire.
Phone wall now.
Get you set.
You want one?
You want foam wall?
Yeah.
There, I'm coming.
I got you.
Are they, which side are they going?
They're just making noise.
I have the angle.
Oh, I hear them.
Oh, they're coming.
They're coming this way.
You're coming a coming Or wherever I'm pinging north north
block entrance.
Oh Yep, I saw I saw them Okay, I'm gonna let you look at
that I got tagged a little bit wait on that What HP I got
one Gonna wall that off.
Oh Yeah, another thing's going out oh behind me so i can't
get in there they got my sensor in the direction of yes i
got motion oh no it's oh they they're they're they threw a
grenade a zone grenade here watch behind us
they're still on the other side i got one okay they cleared
they tried clinging on the left enemies here watch out
careful they flashed is there another flash oh all this they
can't they can't take the off angle they can't take the off
angle i lied yes they can oh there's two i got two more yeah
okay good shot
i looked at the person and chewed my gun at all
Good YouTube, guys.
I'm like, damn, why is it going as a score going so high?
Oh, my God.
Guys, do not look at my accuracy.
Do not look at my accuracy.
Oh, my God.
Where does it show shots fired?
I was spraying down that 1200 RPM.
I tell you what.
Clearly nothing was hitting, though.
heard of yo i feel like suppressing fire on this map you're
right you're right it's zoning it was a zoning shot you know
there's zoning shots you only have 90 more contribution than
me i'll have you know um i will have you know your
contribution was util my contribution was waking up okay
true true you you showed up you showed up that's good i
think gully kept spam calling me and i was Like, I don't
know what this number is.
Can you hang up on Gully?
Do you not have his number saved?
No, I don't think so.
That is such a correct response.
I almost just want to, like, give you a trophy or something.
Thank you.
Well, first I did the classic.
I'm googling the number, so I ignored it.
It doesn't come up with us anything.
I can't believe that happened in your context, man.
What the?
We all use Discord.
Who actually?
numbers what if what if he was getting kidnapped right now
and you was like this is the only number i remember well if
he's okay why doesn't he remember 9-1-1 maybe you're on
speed dial you could have been on this doesn't exist what
grandma what is speed dial been that he's since the 80s dog
that's what in the future we don't know what's called the
context in your phone dog you got a roller decks too you
just start spinning through the cars to find somebody i'm
very sure is i think it's like one round let me check it's
around robin so yeah it's like one round each we freaking
did what that means we did it we made
next match i'm stealing doki's character what the fuck you
won't why are you stealing my character don't play that
character again why not the spice of life why not gomez's
character he was he was doing a lot on that character don't
you want to do more also you don't want to play doki's
character because doki's character has the tightest pants
you could ever imagine what's wrong with tight pants yeah
what's wrong with that you don't want oh you don't want to I
think they're just, they just look really uncomfortable.
Why would you want to subject your character to that?
What if she's into it?
We're live, so I can't say what I was going to say, but
something with all of us know that.
Oh, wait, it is best of three.
Like Ariana Grande won't tell you that her ponytail is
actually really painful if you put your hair in a ponytail
for a really long time.
Apparently it's painful.
I've done that.
Well, it depends on how tight you do it.
Guys, guys, we are, apparently it's best of three.
So we get to choose the map.
All right, Gomez, what map are we doing?
i don't know i mean i don't know uh hit up inferno i'm good
on it have a random function wait why would you do the
hospital dog the hospital again we were not doing so well i
have an idea i i have an idea wait wait yo ask him if they
got mercy can you can you tell him to give me like no mercy
hospital bro gridlock go gridlock here's a war was it his
third hub b you said you like
Hold on.
What map were we just doing?
We did hospital, but we're trying to figure out what we want
to do.
Sorry.
Could you make it quick?
Hello?
Yep.
Could you make it quick?
Oh, yeah.
No, we're talking about the map right now.
We're selecting the map right now.
Third hub B.
Third hub B?
Got that.
Thank you.
Damn.
Can you make it quick?
Wow.
the teacher came in i was like okay i'm sorry i just wanted
to go to the bathroom man too bad too bad also i was gonna
do this i was i was just gonna let it up the chance oh
you're gonna roll it or what's happening oh he was gonna
spin the wheel and let chance i was gonna spin the wheel for
what for the map the map these are these are maps we've just
done this yeah he's gonna Let's.
I'll keep this up for the, I'll keep this up for the next
one.
Are you trying to say we're not going to win the next one?
We're going to go to three maps.
No, no, no, we're going to the next team.
Go into the next team instead.
I believe.
Okay, they did pick defense, so we might be a little fucked
now.
No, no, we have an idea.
We have an idea.
We just have to win our ones.
Let's make sure for it.
i i gave up bro i couldn't all of my pistol ammo breaking
breakables why are you using pistol ammo you have like you
can melee you know i like sure for he just be doing he just
be doing bro i just love that he's just like he's listening
to his heart his heart's telling him to do this
oh that was whoa that was a wet one and then dry one what
the have you never heard that A wet one.
You can tell when someone's hydrated.
Yeah.
Wait, which one's hydrated?
We have to search sides.
The first one was hydrated.
The second one, not really.
Guys, swap sides.
I was still in the, I was still in the, I was still in the,
uh, the, the, um, I mean, I kind of, I'm kind of looking.
Is that okay?
I'm kind of feeling defense on this one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I get it.
Yo, I'm trying to swap.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's okay.
We got Barry on our team, the level 25.
Oh, there you go.
all right guys all we need if we can win one attack round
then then that's all that matters yeah it's game ogre it's
we can do this just one attack i'm running in and dying and
that's the job of an entry frag get in get on kill make
space go to sleep that's true that's true you're not playing
the sniper lady what's the sniper lady's name pull on my
phone and start looking at tiktoks bro oh my god would
sniper even be good in this game it's a body shot body shot
so what she but uh her gadget's really good it lets you see
through walls like you see through the wall so you have to
like put it in that room you have to put like on the wall
and then it goes in the room next to the wall i mean you can
see and you just shoot i don't know i'm just playing dokey's
character okay let's see who's faster i know where she is
you gotta do the stretching you gotta do the stretch thing
it's so good i think it's right the like moth lamp, like
they just hear it and they're just like, I'm gonna watch
this whole thing.
It's so good.
I love that.
And it's it's like such an easy effect.
It doesn't even require any effort.
And it's funnier than anything else that does.
Smirks.
Something that the hit was out for me.
The hit was out for me.
I'll hammer it down.
It's fine.
I was just seeing it.
Yo, yo, sure, Forg.
No, no.
Good choice.
I like your I like your hero selection.
you thank you i'll try to see if she got head and toes uh
how are we doing this what's the plan okay so here's the
plan trailer yeah we're we're gonna go where's trailer oh
all the way on the other side of the map bro no bro a point
a point all you know what let's do it let's do it let's just
go through trailer let's just go the longest route possible
oh badger doesn't believe in seven corners before we get to
the objective with no seconds left he doesn't believe in us
they'll get bored no no no it's a good strat they'll get
bored they'll get bored they'll be like where are they and
then they'll come to us welcome to titanic industry yo check
this out don't no don't touch it don't touch it i'm gonna
show you bro listen to the song bro this song is how do i
mail it that's a waste of resources you shot him up oh my
god what's the matter
damn damn damn guys i think we're gonna go next map guys i'm
pretty how the frick am i arching like that you know what's
up pro it's why did we go to trailer it's so far we went to
trailer because we're getting our freaking cardio in it's so
far i like how the guy with the bomb is i could just melee
the breakables i don't have to shoot them we told you that
they didn't teach you that in yes they did i remember in the
tutorial i don't why are you seeing what you were playing
but that's the barbed wire yeah check it out because look
they're not gonna see that i'm c4 in the other side of the
wall too guys i'm on i'm on bring big i'm on b site wait
you're on site i'm on site there's two on site i'm gonna do
a grenade okay we have one minute remaining guys
I think I hurt someone.
Doki, break the, go there.
Go over there.
Shoot that corner.
There's nobody there.
Make sure not to shoot me.
Okay, I'm running in.
I'm okay, walling.
We'll try to refrag.
Oh, directly ahead of me, directly ahead of me.
Yeah, behind the kegs, behind the kegs, Gomez.
I see him.
Yep, yep.
Oh, I got one.
Another one.
Okay.
I'm on B.
Oh!
Man.
Why was I so low?
And won the long hallway near sure four.
Yeah.
Where sure four is looking.
How do I even get into the side?
Uh, FYI, you only got 10 seconds.
Oh my god, we have 10 seconds.
Go, go, go, play, play, play, play, play.
Yeah, so you gotta play.
Lord, how does it go?
Go, go, play, play, play, play.
Just play.
Just go, play.
I'm planting.
We're all planting.
He's planting.
He's sensitive.
Okay.
Hold on, I have an idea.
Anyway, I got another one.
Okay, I have my position.
This is my position.
This is my home.
Okay, okay, okay.
Thou shalt show no fear.
And eyes are not alone.
We did it, guys.
We did it.
I can see my king heavily just slowly meleeing the wall
trying to get in.
How the fuck do we get through the heavy reinforcements?
You gotta use the heavyware.
That was plenty of time.
That was at least 300 milliseconds.
Bro, there was like two seconds left.
It was like...
I'm like, dude, you don't understand, bro.
I can play that time.
The spawn across the map strat worked.
They probably started playing the mom head-ass.
See, look at it.
You fucking doubted me.
Okay, I'm not doing that shit again.
I just like that at all.
all right you and me we got the rush not they could they
could do the they can do the trailer we got the rush okay i
got loading zone i got loading enemy team is vtubers right
their adhd probably kicked in and they got bored not even
kidding though that's actually true they're just like where
did they go oh watching max or videos in the corner i know
oh no he's dead oh no they got him they got him guys guys
this is bad i have the bomb gg is the if you throw g why you
just press g listen to that banger it's a banger bro i'm
gonna put a trap okay i'm gonna throw a motion detector i'm
throwing a motion scanning enemy spotted inside all right
all right
watch this in this corner in this corner in that corner oh
shit can i wall I have an idea.
Doogie, doogie, watch this one.
I don't know.
I got a plan.
Oh, wait, there's a radio.
I missed her.
Oh, what the fuck is here?
Shoot her.
I got her.
Nice.
I got one.
Look at that one.
In the corner, in the corner, in the corner.
Oh, she ran, she ran, she ran.
She ran.
It's me.
Hey, bro.
I can't even get crushed.
Just press the bombs here for.
What the fuck?
Put it in.
Man down!
Shoot him!
They got him!
Please!
Do you really want me to avenge you?
Oh my god, no!
There's one more.
One more.
Sure fork.
All right, there you go.
I'm not about to let a crocodile beat me, bro.
I walk on land.
You swim.
Move.
I don't think you wanted me to avenge you because the person
that killed you was a teammate.
That's not true.
If I had avenged you, it would have became a 1v1.
I don't think we would want the 1v1, guys.
I don't think you're...
Wait, I'm fracking out this round though.
Oh, shit.
Let's look at your accuracy after.
Don't worry about that.
You guys never heard of suppressing fire.
People don't understand accuracy by volume, and it's kind of
credentialing.
I'm going with your wall.
Sorry, I don't know the math.
You got calculator for me.
Hey, does anybody else want the decryptor?
Yeah, I'll tell you.
I'll tell you.
Do not give it to them.
Do not give them.
I can be trusted with the decryptor, though.
I might put it on A if we want B.
I'm just feeling a little saucy, you know?
They're very nice to each other.
It's fine.
Alright, girl squad.
Let's go.
I'm going the long way.
Make sure for our thing a little stroll together.
That's a reinforced wall.
How do we go through that?
You break it.
I blow it over.
You're punching it for like six years, man.
Just throw a grenade.
Oh, and we have to break this wall.
Enemy gadget destroyed.
Okay.
Follow me.
I know where I'm going.
I'm getting close so I can scan.
Oh, okay.
I'm on your scan.
Boom.
And he was spotted right there.
And he spotted.
Oh, wait.
I'm lining up my grenade.
Wait, bro, they're not even on A.
Oh, they threw a grenade here.
Goodbye.
Wait, what?
I can't get there yet.
I'm wall off.
Wait, how do we get there?
Don't keep breaking this wall.
Wait, this wall?
No, that's where we just came from.
No, you doofus.
Wait, they're over there.
Where's our bomb at?
You know where...
Got it.
Don't you remember this?
Wait, don't...
We beat you in the back of the head.
Unfortunately, we beat you in the back of the head.
Me?
Oh, you actually meleeed.
You actually just ran up the freaking bomb button there.
Wow.
You actually ran up the game.
That's cool.
Bro, that's how it is right here, bro.
I don't play no games.
Your own kind?
You- I'm evil, bro.
I'm on my nefarious shit right now.
This guy has a shotgun.
I'm gonna run up and shotgun.
We're defense right now.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, any of them are pretty good.
Oh yeah, he has mines too.
The guy has mines, so you can put mines, like, in places.
What the Sigma?
Yeah.
Irm, what the Grog?
Oh.
Okay.
I got an AK-47.
and a saunoff and uh okay okay i'm gonna put this here and
then i'm gonna redeploy this that's not a mine it is a mine
you walk through that oh it's a mime oh we're no not my oh
this looks like a freaking hammer
this is my territory whoever comes into my territory mindset
smirks Sticky out!
Razor wires down!
Alright, I'm ready.
Almost, bro.
He's ready to miss here for now.
I heard some gunfire, so I'm gonna run towards it
immediately.
That's very smart.
This is my territory.
I got motion!
You do, twin?
Let me see how money's spreading.
Whoops.
Nah, this shit, gallery department.
Oh, I hear the chime.
Wait, where was that?
Where did that?
Over here.
I was hoping I catch somebody lacking.
They're going to run into my mine.
Oh, that's a grenade.
They're coming.
Oh, my detector's over here.
My detector's detecting.
They're here.
Why are you making the wall?
I'm barricading.
Wait, don't shoot.
Don't shoot.
I'm a barricade.
Enemy down.
That was a good shot.
Oh.
No.
and we down and we down Please remember that time I killed
you don't remember that time you pick me up bro.
Fuck you bitch That's fucking revenge That's karma right
there There's one more over here on his ass Oh, he's all the
way there
Kachon Well, hey, we'll avenge you.
Oh, go go all sides hold it i got i got him i got him yeah
my one kill that was one time i shot my gun yeah baby we won
and that's my hero academia right there
we did it guys yeah we did it oh my 17.9 i feel do not look
at contributions smirks do not look at badges act do not
look at Dodger-Zach.
No, look at my act.
Look at my act.
Wait, my accuracy is insane.
Two shotgun shells at the end of the game just to make that
number happen, so.
You're welcome.
Look, I shot, I only shot my gun once to kill somebody.
My jaw is unhinged.
Look at that, guys.
At least you didn't have the lowest damage in the guys.
We're making it to day two, guys.
We're gonna make it.
Wait, I had Diga Omega damage.
oh shit what you did yo dokey you know that your gun fires
bullets right yeah yeah yeah but then you know doesn't gun
you use your gun to destroy walls though right what these
stats are telling me is dokey barely hit anyone and when she
did shoot she missed all of her that is not true i took the
shot that i literally killed i took the shot that counts the
rest were at the walls
crazy you see if i took the shot that counts and that got me
a kill what do we do now we wait oh i was intentionally
missing and even i got six seven so wait what do we want to
do this map again i feel like this map was our easiest map
this is my favorite map all right what was it called i
already forgot the map name third hubby third hubby
look at that see guys we can do attack i knew at the moment
we learned how to work together oh we did not work together
no sir for went in good i got a pick
what is sir for saying yeah but he's our top frag we all won
our ones like yeah yeah yeah i want my one yeah exactly i
want my ones yeah
we just hit winner ones i just really gotta know who shot
gomez there's like an evil six guy or something like for
some reason uh it's just like reminiscing that someone here
it's like it's like a third force that i can't comprehend no
we're still playing apparently the other teams are still in
their games how close oh they're like close close yeah okay
these guys yeah these These guys are Valorant players.
Both teams.
Oh, we're caught up.
Yes, it is.
So they know how to hold corners.
They're all just walking together.
Oh, my God.
They're so slow.
They're like... They're so slow.
You should be running from the opposite side.
P89 corners before you get to the site.
True, true.
I need to use the bathroom.
P-break.
If we just took a swig of something, I heard that flink.
Dude, you're making me thirsty.
That was me.
I was drinking the funny subs.
Shit, good.
Yeah, I just ran out of mine.
I'm going to refill mine.
Funny subs.
Yeah.
You don't drink gamer subs, dog?
Why not?
It's delicious, and I'm going to show.
I'm going to show.
You know, I just don't know much about it.
Could you care to tell me?
Could you care to tell me about this flavor drink please
okay so it's an energy drink and when you drink it it
doesn't feel like you just got a root canal but I just drink
Coke Zero Coke Zero like Coke Zero is good Coke Zero is just
more just brown water I'm sorry man brown tasty brown water
I'd rather have brown water
does it have the same caffeine profile of 45 milligrams like
I mean myself, by the way, but it's every I was all this is
sound good.
It's 34.
It's 34 right now That's actually a pretty good amount just
a teeny tiny bit.
It's actually a good idea 34 per 12 fluid ounces But yeah,
anyway, thank you again for playing spot for the sponsor.
You want to support me in the stream and the tournament So
feel free to click on the link in the chat or in the
description But no also go check out the main broadcast
check out my dokeybird twitch because that's where the main
broadcast is playing right now of Luffy and Ace doing a
handshake?
Oh, what?
We're talking about how, or I'm talking about Adam Sandler,
is it going to be in one piece?
Oh, yeah, I saw that tweet.
I saw, I don't think they can afford Adam Sandler.
Can they?
Just they can.
There's no way.
I mean, it is Netflix, yeah.
It is Netflix, so most likely, I think they have a contract
with Adam Sandler, too, that he has to be with them for a
while.
all right mudas team one who are we just go back did you say
contract with a w no contract i think you're i think there's
something around with your yeah yeah i don't know maybe my
discord is like broken all the time so i come back and i
just say contract i'm like what wait i can unlock this guy
wait the person with the off is locked yeah you can unlock
him you they gave us codes wait where's the codes scroll up
you have to have the currency you actually weren't lying you
just he just he hops on the game i mean no so you were just
playing like i'm sorry oh my god so he was just playing with
like the the free freebies also we're playing as a team that
won against subrosa moody's team they're also playing a
hospital what the heck the codes are in a screenshot man i
have to type Oh, use copy and paste.
No, just scroll up.
Scroll up.
Yeah, scroll up.
Oh, dude, that's me.
That has my name on it.
Only the first code works, by the way.
The second one is broken for some reason.
So you can pick.
Where do I put it?
You go to, you press Escape Settings, and then Redeem Code
at the very end.
Render Scale?
It's more info.
It's at Settings and then more info.
Redeem Code.
code okay then it's the second one it looks like someone
stole my code you said the first one then maybe yours is the
second one mine was the first one that worked yeah i bet see
they got 9 000 credits the first one you body safe pretty
cool sure don't listen to the words i say
all right i put the new 4g wait i don't even have a minute
put our results on it i don't have of them no you can only
you can only three yeah i was looking at my phone who's
saying wait this guy has a shield the one yeah yeah then
like no i can also i don't know if it was you or is badger
badger was singing what you got some of my guests putting
4g's on your jeep no it's i'm in the drive
no no if you want to know the meme i was listening to it's
like that one it's like the cover of that character from a
lot i'll send it to heavenly who said it to you so dude i'm
talking about the next one uh who is it hey go mess me i i
don't know the horse game well enough to know who you're
talking about but it's this one oh good oh yes dude i love
that yeah i was i was telling heavenly about this because we
were playing the game a little bit i keep seeing like the
armpit licking from you know what i'm talking about not why
are you looking at them why are you what is your twitter
algorithm this is involuntary look it's the horse girls it's
the horse girls i'm i like the game okay i like it you know
the crazy thing it's called a for you page for reasons
really yes if you click on it yes it'll show up
it on my feed because you keep clicking on it because if you
click on it oh yeah this is a self-exposed it's completely
psyopping our whole society yeah i think liking it also
doesn't help so that's why it's terrible like you see a
really hot woman you click on her to see if she's ai and
then it's like oh you like that says the algorithm it's like
no i want to know if it was ai it's your whole your whole
twitter feed it's just like ai girls oh no no i don't have
that And then you got to like really interact with like
gardening content or like, I don't know, something
radicalizing.
And then it's like, okay, now I got this.
And at least this isn't like AI generated.
I like one cooking video and it was all my feed.
Yeah, because it's for you.
Yeah, I like you just saw that.
Yeah, that might be kind of cool.
Just click on my tweets and then you'll just get my tweets.
And then you can read my tweets.
Same with my tweets, too.
Let me open your tweets.
Let me look up your tweets.
I'm not going that far.
What do you have on your tweets?
Russian Badger.
or you tweet about mr badger that's strong right now you
follow no one yeah you don't even follow anybody no list so
that nobody gets but no i keep i keep on follow them so i
just yeah i just keep a list just keep a list you just keep
a list you just keep what do you just like and then just oh
just click him oh so like a twitter the twitter listing so
you click on the listing and then yep wait she got a switch
on her glock What are you looking at?
I'm trying out the op character.
She got a switch on this thing.
Oh, heavenly.
We got EJ in a Volvo ad.
This is so cool.
They got Drusky swinging phones around.
She's getting Volvo checks now.
Good for her.
Yo, what?
Can you not headshot in this game?
Yeah.
What is his Twitter?
You can.
is it the russian badger my twitter is at d a russian badger
because they only allow 15 characters and not 16 so i can't
fit my name legally it won't let me aim at their head well
it's already one it's already uh uh one shot uh kill for
body shot yeah but on an ar how do i i don't know i never
played this game oh the lobbies up all right we gotta join
someone invite me into the lobby No.
You mean no.
No.
Wait, does the number show up if I type it or...
Oh, yes, it does.
Okay, I got hot it.
802.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa.
We just get randoms in there that it's just more fun.
Once we're all in, we can say the last few digits.
Yeah, yeah, once every...
Wait, no, because then they can go to the observer.
No, because they can go to the observer.
observers hell yeah brother the last two digits are funny
badger no you're giving away everything but the third to
last digit all right don't say anything else by saying that
that might actually be enough dude you can brute force that
nine digit dude come on now badger uh you're on the wrong
team man come over and we miss you man i want to ready
change i want to win so let me just yeah i want to yeah i
want to get killed by my own yo they got i carly on the oh
kamarly all right what no that's not fucking i carly come on
i thought it was i carly at first i want to be i carly she's
still there give me give it all right i'm refilling my gamer
subs don't start the game yet i'm gonna get water too they
don't even give us a countdown they kind of just start it
well they They started when everyone readies up.
So you could, like, stall it.
Please press ready.
Yeah, that's what happened to me.
All right, I'm going to get water.
I'll be right back.
Here, Badger, I finally found your Twitter.
Let me see what you've been tweeting.
No, there's too much text.
I'm sorry.
I can't read this.
Badger, what the hell are your tweets?
This is too much for my ADHD.
Oh, hell no.
No, this is, I'm not.
reading paragraphs after paragraph of all your tweets.
Of what?
No, no, no.
I just, I just went to his post and it's just, I scrolled to
one point and it's just lines and lines and lines of text.
What?
It's his little personal biography.
Is it?
His personal diary.
Oh, I feel, oh, I see like a dick now.
Okay, sorry.
Okay.
What?
No, I just, I I thought half this was how far did you scroll
how far did you scroll like not that far just the January
3rd to December 9th we literally oh hey Gomez I think it's
super funny when people say the word scrolling because I
picture them with like actual ancient ancient scrolls like
looking at papers and surrounded by tapestries and I think
it's funny you have a very yeah you do very creative
sideways croc joy what the hell what oh wait yeah we want to
observe our tactics because we're so goading the game yeah
they're like we want to know how they did that yeah uh wait
how did doki rely entry fracking eight time die bro how did
she get 1.6 percent accurate yeah how did that happen where
i parse through what do you say yo it is definitely i have a
50 90 and i have a 99 50 x3d and i have a gig up and gig
down this is not my fault i think it's your fault i might be
your fault i don't should have a better i think this is you
click it's on all right or we're attacking our defense i
didn't check when i went to neo gaff and ordered a virus
that's not my fault true hey you want to try this video game
i've been working on oh yeah yeah yeah can you try on my
platform and make sure to share it to your friends too
should i throw and play the sniper girl she's not a throw
she's pretty good her detail is really good what if i miss
my shot don't i trust you to not do that i'm gonna say la
gladiators widowmaker player la gladiators sure for
widowmaker head king's row player like you got this blushes
please hit that shot hit myself with a rock hits myself with
a rock hit myself with a rock dude it's so weird being
around people that are good at video games it's confusing
like you just see a shot and you hit it like What is that
like?
You're like, wait, what?
He's actually dead?
It's 1v4 and then the 4s just start disappearing and then
it's 1v0.
This is weird.
Wait, where are we going?
Are we not doing like we did last time?
Why is that?
Lord Headass is going to the custom match.
Yeah, Lord Headass is a trailer right now.
It's time for some cardio.
Wait, who has the bomb?
Oh my god, hit us.
Oh my god.
Oh, there's Ruth having some cardio there, yo.
Let's get on walks in.
He has the bomb.
all right the razor oh they're wall banging me these guys
are good yeah they're valid players of course they're good
guys like play video games yeah i'm protecting mine sweeper
guy myself aren't you even that's uh that's that's their
motions detector how do i get rid of it um we have to go in
shiffer what the are you doing right now clear getting rid
of that smirks right Checking corner, clear.
Left side, clear.
Looking left, clear.
Right, left, right, left.
Oh, I got you.
Yo, he's in there, fry him.
Oh, go there.
Oh, my God.
I'm on, I'm on, oh.
Oh.
Okay, I'm good luck.
I'm crossing.
Cross to me, cross to me.
Help me, I'm dying.
There's no way I can fucking do this.
Just cross.
Oh, my God.
What are you saying?
I'm at the conclusion.
decision got us both killed that is not true okay my and
your debt is your fault okay guys i think we might need to
work together here even the first team that actually is
ready to shoot back bro what do we do sure for even if she
tried getting tree once she died her grenade was going to
fall right next to you
regardless because she had her grenade grenade that whole
time no the enemy was about to fucking grenade you that's
what no you had a grenade i already used my grenade that was
my motion it dropped next to him that was my motion
detective did it detect you because i don't think you got
motion twin i have the green i have the bomb now let's all
they can shoot back guys they can All right, so this is
what's going to happen.
I'm going to stim.
And it's going to make everyone see.
I've been married long time ago.
Yo, let's just rush in.
I don't know.
Last time we did that.
They were manning that last time.
They won't do it twice.
They were all banging that last time.
Yo, they were all banging that last time.
All right.
No, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
I'm ready to boost.
All right.
Going.
Oh, my.
Oh, I'm reloading my booster.
Three, two, one, go.
That shit, you won't.
There is it.
You got motion.
Really got right here.
There's a guy right here.
Yeah, I got it right here.
Like 86 different angles.
Just push in.
I can't.
There's literally, yes, in front of us.
Peek it.
Bro, just hold your breath.
What?
You're going?
How does that miss?
Oh.
Oh my.
I got guys.
Not gonna lie.
Their util game is pretty good.
Their util is a lot better than our util for sure.
They don't have enough bullets to shoot all of us at once.
Just push.
Right across.
All right.
How about this?
How about I go a shield character?
If I go a shield, do you think we got it?
No, that's a good choice.
Do that.
All right.
That's what we were.
And then the bullet didn't hit him.
Maybe you missed.
Oh yeah.
I keep forgetting you've been playing the sniper character
this whole time.
Maybe you just missed.
Oh, we got this, bro.
But how?
The little line was on him.
Okay, Patrick has to ask the Bob.
I swear it's going to work this time.
Just like last time.
Yeah, I'm smoking a cigarette and I got a giant hammer, so
don't worry.
Yeah, just like last time.
So what's going to happen is, right?
So here's where y'all go this way.
I go this way.
Easy entry.
And when y'all get blown up here, I'll be here to cross and
then, you know what I'm saying?
Or or you can put a miner.
I can't click it.
Okay, whatever.
I know what you're doing till this time.
This will work.
Hey, check us out.
No, no, no.
Check us out.
Ooh, watch it.
I'm happy.
I'm ready to click.
Hey, look at.
All right, he's on the right side right here.
Oh, oh, he's on the right side right here.
Oh, oh, guy front right.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
You know, I need some help here.
Okay, so what?
I'm throwing a motion.
I'm showing emotion.
Yeah.
There you go.
Let's go that way.
Let's get that guy.
You walk over me.
You can shoot above my head.
I saw that guy.
You saw that guy.
You saw that guy right there.
Right up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Guys, I got a kill.
Can I shoot over you?
Oh, no, you cannot.
No, you cannot.
Oh, they like sliverpick me.
Not one.
You're going to get him though.
You got him.
Motion sensor.
Okay.
You can melee.
Watch how to run in.
I'm not sure for.
You just got one in the corner of my body.
You have the bomb.
Oh, I know.
And I have the shield.
You have the bomb!
I'm here.
I'm getting set up.
Plant.
Hold on.
Oh, there's a dude directly in front of Gomez.
Putting.
Planting.
I'm trying to help.
Smoking.
Oh, put the bomb down, twin.
Big smoker.
Watch behind us.
Where's the bomb?
It's right here.
Oh, it's right here.
Right here.
Come here.
Dogey.
Come on.
Here we go.
Keep the window.
I'm trying!
Oh, dice, dice, dice, dice!
Get on one!
Get on!
I won't kill this bitch!
Hayao!
Oh my god, we got a point!
Oh my god!
Wow.
See, I told y'all, bro.
The splitting the tension spell is like unbeatable.
People just can't not look where something goes boom.
Nice siege players are actually engaging.
Oh my god.
Guys, also, Trifor did kill like three.
No, that's not true.
I haven't killed anybody yet.
That's not true.
All right.
Defense.
Badger, badger.
You're just waiting for defense.
You're a defense player.
I'm gonna blow someone up with my- Not true.
I'm just getting peaked really well.
Some of these guys are just good.
Yeah, yeah.
You can be better.
What happened?
Wait, we're good.
I don't have a, I don't impact grenades.
Fuck.
I got, I got a C4 where you wanna go.
Oh.
All right, that sounds good.
Good plan, good plan.
We'll talk to him over here.
I like that plan.
All right.
head us head us i have an idea i have an idea okay yeah i'm
gonna i'm gonna put a wall here super early they're gonna be
like what they're gonna be like what the fuck can i not pick
this up and then and then whenever whenever they break one
of the walls we can just shoot this and just i'll crouch and
you you you stay up and we blast yeah yeah yeah here we go
here we go here we go and hold on how ironic would it be if
they shot it's the right all right to us okay okay ready
Wait, three, two, one.
These fuckers, what did they do?
Okay, there's people here, there's people there.
Oh, they're behind us, dude, wait, hold on.
Oh, oh, oh, that's awkward.
I got smoked down though, so they can't go back.
They're, oh, hey, they're moving right there.
My gun stopped shooting.
Oh.
Two, I got two.
There's just one more on me, there's one more on me.
There you go.
Oh my God, there's, I'm ejecting myself.
I'm ejecting myself for experimental drugs.
and you're getting wall back you're getting wall back yo
what the heck was damn that guy just mouse is dying uh so my
mouse might be dying i'm not kidding that guy has dokey
stream on a second monitor yeah it's not like like wall
banging you right now hold on bro i'm scared bro i was
clicking my gun it just went nah i'm good i'm one break did
you did you I had 12 bullets.
Yeah, no.
Wait.
I might have let go of rank.
Did you let go of?
If you use a util and then don't switch to your gun, it
still has your util out even though it has no charges and
then you don't shoot.
I might have let go of rank like I'm not kidding because I
like snuck in and I was like, oh, I got him.
Okay, I'm gonna put razor wire here.
The little hole that you made them sort of.
razor wire up anyone need a quick shot hey i need to make i
need to put that razor wire hey it's my med pack if i do you
no i'm trying to put the razor wire by the way i'm walling
you all short forward not because i hate you but because uh
you need to be contained bro you're like a demon you know we
gotta we gotta don't ever come for me i'm used to it
yeah which point which point b They're on site B.
Why the fuck were none of us at B?
I was studying a ball.
Because it's funny.
I might have been studying a ball.
Oh my god.
They're over here.
I'm watching one a lot.
Coming down the hallway, heavenly.
You're so fucking dead.
You're so dead.
I know.
I realized last second.
Well, you got one.
Don't worry, guys.
Let me use this.
Yeah, heal up.
Heal up.
Heal up, twin.
Oh, well, you got time.
You definitely got so much time.
All right, do it again.
You're not full.
Do it again.
You're not.
Why did this guy push me?
I was going to go on the plane.
You were healing.
You're not allowed to do that.
Streep sniper.
Yo, those dudes are really skilled.
All right, team.
We can win the next one.
So we got this.
Let's all turn on monitors.
Yeah, yeah, now that, yeah, let's all just get ready for
real this time.
We're just fucking around.
We're just giving them a chance, you know?
Do we want to select the side or the map?
I don't think, do you want to attack or defense?
Let's attack.
Just attack.
We got this.
Wait, attack or defense, guys.
All right, we'll do defense.
Do you?
Let's do a defense.
Let's show them the power.
All right, defense.
All right.
That's the hardest part.
All right, guys, guys.
This time we're locked in, right?
Well, not me, but I hope you guys are.
I'm just running around.
How many bullets do you have in your saw, Doki?
Two?
The one that hit and the one that missed.
That's it.
You have two bullets in an M249 saw?
Yeah.
just two but we make it count i don't think that's right
that's a belt-fed machine gun i don't think that's right
yeah we make it count two bullets which is 200 underground
box two bullets we're carrying a two yeah yeah we are we
gotta go to the other side the other side get let us in
Oh, I think my new rings are here.
Let's go.
Nice.
Oh.
I believe in this.
Oh, whoops.
Yeah, my bad.
Am I on the wrong side?
Someone is.
I didn't send the message.
Switching sides.
Dude, I didn't know.
We got auto modded.
Oh, my God, bro.
Hang on.
My own teammates are pushing me.
Just like, I'm just doom scrolling Twitter.
and tell me what to do.
Looking at more armpits, bro.
Yeah, are you looking at more armpits and women?
No, I haven't come across of it yet.
I don't even know.
That's why I'm scrolling so fast.
I put a crack in my screen how fast I'm scrolling.
Oh my god, my thumbs.
I instead have a Umamusame WhatsApp car in my feed now.
That's awesome.
I'll send it to you.
Send it to you, uh no i want all of you to see this i'll put
in i'll put in team team chat or team general yeah we need
to we need to get the team morale up with this man
awesome oh it took my discord
red house a please press ready all right guys press ready
Hey!
Oh, whoops.
This gives me a chance to move my Spotify over to my right
source because there we go.
Your right source?
Yes.
So it was on the source that Discord was, like audio source.
I couldn't turn it down.
So I couldn't hear y'all because I had my music play.
That makes a lot more sense.
You're playing deaf this entire time.
Yes.
For he was doing that.
Are you fucking kidding me?
He does that for other tournaments.
To be fair though.
That's how he locks in.
FCP remix is one of the best songs ever.
Sorry.
Hmm.
What happened?
All right.
I believe in us guys.
for real this time we were just warming up i also believe in
us in my hands too bad no regrets sounds like lincoln park
are you singing lincoln park fall of choice or am i dumb i
don't know what that is uh
bro i'm not even kidding i might like i might try to build a
cosplay for this character he's clean i like him dude i just
need like a wig i i don't know if anyone's ever told you
this but i can hear it through your headphones like i hear
it yeah it plays at full volume wait i forgot the pick oh my
god it's fine it's fine it's fine i i have med kids he's
throwing he's throwing You know, I have my silence.
Look at my silence deagle.
Holy shit.
Nice deed.
You James Bond.
Oh, God.
Why am I allowed to make that reference?
I don't know.
What reference?
Yeah, what reference?
No reference.
Wait, this is the first time I've set up a barricade.
Yeah, you hold F.
I'm setting the barricade for this area.
I'm barricading.
Guys, I'm barricading the door.
Guys, do you think we can win this guys?
I'm barricading.
How many barricades do I get?
But Lord had us.
Unlimited.
We all get a...
What's up?
They're mine.
They're not coming here.
They're shooting this.
They're coming in the direction of Heavenly and I.
Check this out.
I see this.
Oh, check this out.
Motion sensor.
Throwing them all.
Check this out.
Barricaded it.
Oh, oh.
Oh my god!
Oh, they just blasted my ass.
They busted the door next to the door.
Damn, their infill is so good.
Guys, oh!
Trust me with me!
No!
Wait, wait.
We died.
Wait, I have an idea.
Of course you have an idea that might be able to be...
The wall exploded.
It's true to your mental drugs.
I'm coming.
So...
Oh my god, it worked!
You guys won!
You like that?
Going for Medkit.
Okay.
All right, all right, all right, all right.
I'll peep this, peep this, peep this, right?
They're really good at busting in together, right?
they pick a direction they go so all we have to do is
reinforce the site and leave that is true oh oh that is
that's smart that's smart i got impact grenades and then
i'll do i'll do oh do i need do we need walls i think i just
use the shotgun you can add extra walls if you want just
make the site look like we're there and then we leave yeah i
have a better i like it what's your yeah what's your plan
that plans for me i'm gonna dress up like it you Who's the
character?
That plans for me, don't worry.
I'm going to go on the other side of the map so they'll
never expect someone to be behind them.
Oh, damn.
True, true.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Board it all up and everything.
And then we just leave.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
You're trying to go through this door.
No, it's okay.
I'm just, I'm just walking behind you, man.
Hold on.
Where do I go?
I'm also trying to, yeah, there we go.
All right.
I'm leaving.
Boom.
Okay.
Motion detector placed.
Fires down.
We got motion.
Don't worry.
Motion sensor placed.
Oh my God.
They're all here.
They're coming.
I may have sent ever.
I may have sent up everything in A.
Oh, nice.
See, I told you.
Oh, I told you.
I'm behind you.
We're after.
My brain is in the corner.
This is hell, dude.
There's only two left alive!
He crouched!
Fuck!
Do you have to crouch?
Yeah, I didn't know how to- Okay, I got him!
I got him!
To aim down, you hold control.
You don't have to hold control.
Yes.
Motion detector placed.
Oh, they know I'm here, by the way.
Motion in the kitchen?
In the kitchen?
Yeah, directly ahead of you.
I got him!
Yeah!
What did I say, bro?
I was a sacrificial lamb.
Yeah, the motion works.
Do it again, bro.
Yeah, just do it again.
Yes, bro.
I'm a bit lost though in this area, but we could do it
again.
Yeah.
No, I'm, well, I have definitely just not lost at all.
They're probably going to expect that this time and just go
to site.
Oh, that's true.
And if they go to, as long as we have, as long as we're near
site, but not on site, they have to figure out where we are
first.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They don't have like a way to see ahead of us, you know?
We just stay like, you know, like B, right?
We just stay in like this general area down here, and they
go in, we shoot them in the back.
Okay, we're just gonna reinforce a little bit.
Reinforcing?
Yeah, swam it down a little bit.
Go over there.
I got motion over here.
Got motion over here.
Wait, do I have infinite barricades?
No, we have 14.
The top left, the top left.
Dude, top left.
Yeah, I think it's a cheerful.
Yeah, I just barricade the entire map.
Konichi Wagwan, Mina Slime.
Phone wall now!
Oh, I hear people over there.
You could never say that again.
Watch find us!
What's wrong, Kroski Kudu?
Guys, they're heading to me!
They're heading to me and I'm a bit fucked up here.
Oh, they're over by me too.
They did a flashbang, but I didn't get a flashboard bang.
Oh my god, you farted on me!
Did you bring out a run of me?
Is there a way way out here?
They're bringing down there.
They boosted.
I don't have walls.
Yeah, mollies.
Mollies.
Oh my god, they're coming over.
Don't need help.
Wait, I hit him with giga grenades.
Yo, behind me.
Motion detecting.
Got it.
One more in kitchen.
Motion detecting.
Got him.
Nice.
Yo, me.
One more in kitchen.
I got you.
Nice.
I told you, bro.
They're too busy trying to get kills.
They're over here.
Right here.
Oh my god.
come on wait you actually want it would be blocked his ass
oh now it's our turn oh no that was that match was me
hitting super gomez in the back with my toxic gas because he
ran in front of it nothing wrong with a little brap on the
homie you know just the far don't worry guys i'll get us
some pics smirks guys so like how do we do this
man i'll go to the swimming pool i'll see you in the parking
lot i'll see you at the main entwins yeah well i'll see you
at the garden okay so how where are we meeting up guys how
do we attack yeah how do we yeah we meet up on site remember
our attack plan is win your one oh yeah win your one just go
in win that one give me the bomb give me the bomb i have an
idea give me the bomb press g yeah it dropped go pick it up
g g i'm pressing g oh my god you re-binded your g didn't you
i got it okay no no i did not i got some bad news me when i
re-bind the most vital game it's from g to on f4 like i
don't know i'm bored don't
worry motion motion sensor place motion wait they're using
wait wait they just gave me the freest plant bomb ever
that's cringe wait That's pretty cool.
We're gonna be doing our plane.
Wait, wait, wait.
They might be doing our plane.
Sure, help me.
Sure, for help me.
Sure for help me.
You're fine.
Okay.
Can we like wall bang?
How do we defend that?
I have grenades.
Okay.
I'm going to the other side.
They're moving towards side, but they're not on it yet.
I'm just trying to keep blue grenades on it so we can see
when they come in.
Motion.
No, wait.
That might block us off.
Just be careful.
They farted.
I got one!
Oh, grenade.
Grenade.
They're all looking at me.
You know, he crouched on me.
He's on my body.
He's in that room.
I see him.
I'm ready.
I'm ready for him.
Oh, my God.
Nice, nice.
One more over here.
I'm down.
There you go.
Oh my God.
We're so smart.
See, they tried my plan, but they didn't go deeper.
So I went deeper than their flank on the flank, bro.
what me and gomez saw which is them literally foaming off
their only entrance to their own site the other exit and
then just planting it as soon as i saw it i'm like what yes
bro i hit that every time i went oh shit i bomb does anyone
buy i threw the bomb away y'all give it to me give it to me
you have the bomb you just pick it up okay i don't think
okay i don't think no it'll happen a second no it'll happen
they're about to they're about to like deep deep flank so
just rush instead this time this this time sure for we're
going to we're going to wait okay you can do that right
we're gonna wait and let them make the noise you can't even
go in the base don't even try to chain a wild beast no no
but spend a whole minute outside just walking around me to
wait and he's running around leave by no i'm literally
crouch walking you see me leave by example i got my ass to
the floor what do you mean i'm running i got overwatch your
sniper yeah watch over me come on don't make any mistakes oh
oh i saw somebody on the cross wait do you go mess are you
about to see this watch this yeah waiting i killed one okay
holy Is it just like my demons?
Is it just registered swing?
Okay.
They reinforced that.
You shot me!
You fucking idiot!
What the fuck was that?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Hold on.
Watch this.
Okay.
The ultimate throw.
To our right, to our right, Gomez.
Oh my god, yeah, I see him.
I'll throw mine too?
You're shooting that wall for two years.
It's working.
Why are you complaining?
Don't stand up.
I got one.
I got one going.
Okay.
There's something going in.
You guys see that guy?
I'm going in.
Right here.
I got it.
On the reload.
I'm gonna off crouching.
Crouching.
Crouching down to the ground.
I'm glancing.
Glancing.
Just glancing.
Planting.
Make it.
Last one is inside.
Inside.
She's just there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I know where she is.
I know.
I'm motioning.
I'm motioning here.
Yo, go get them, twin.
She's very good.
Show them the motion, twin.
Yeah, they see.
Good job.
Whoa.
We got around.
Bro, I'm telling you, they can't sit still that one minute
wait.
I'm telling you, bro.
Can't predict us.
They never know what's going on.
coming next we don't know what they won't know you were like
they're valerie players i was like oh that means they have
like one thing in their mind they want to get a kill what if
you don't give a super gomez shooting that the whole time
what do you mean a fucking iron wall i'm shooting the your
iron wall yeah don't get mad at me it's not my fault i'm i
was partnering up with a guy that you're talking to 790
contribution smirks yeah what was your contribution gomez
what the fuck were you doing oh i don't i don't know i i
don't know how to check it again how do i check it oh of
course you didn't i think you can swap sites on defense if
you hit e on the operator select oh can that's true i don't
want to do that did we just learn some tech oh i don't want
to do If any of these guys have practiced taking sites, if
we just switch the site, then they're going to be so
grieved.
They're going to be like, where the fuck am I?
Okay, you're doing it because I have no clue how to do it.
Well, they're probably going to pick defense first, so I'm
going to switch to observe.
Let's see.
They're thinking.
They're thinking right now.
They're strategizing.
Oh, it's the hospital.
Oh, my God.
Okay, do we want attack or defense?
Attack or D?
I feel like...
I could do like a...
I could do a coin flip.
What were we good at?
I don't even remember.
What were...
Oh, we're already good at defense.
We're good at defense.
All right, I'll go D then.
Defense.
There we go.
I spelled defense wrong.
Defense.
Ooh, defense!
That's not...
That's correct.
No, I spelled defense right.
Oh, that's not...
No, no, it's right.
It's right.
I just wanted to see if you guys noticed.
Oh, that's...
Yeah.
I mean, if you're British, it's different.
All right, we're so ready.
Oh, just one.
The British spelled defense different.
Probably.
They spelled with a C.
Yeah, I spelled with a C.
I thought that was only...
I'm from Canada originally, and yeah, you spelled with a C.
Commonwealth countries spell it with a yeah I was gonna say
but then ENCE I was just testing who's American and who's
Canadian they spell it American spell with an S and
Canadians aluminum aluminum oh I think aluminum is dumb as
well and if you say yeah I just think it's stupid aluminum
is too much too many syllables aluminum and He's getting
like 10 IQ points by saying aluminium.
What?
I love that video.
What is this?
A ghoul.
This.
A cadaver.
A manna.
A casket.
They disabled switching sites and stuff, I think.
No!
I see the prepared option there, but it's like great.
Oh, I see it, yeah.
that's fine bro oh same plan as before bro all right we're
sight maxing don't worry about it yeah yeah same plan okay
oh oh gomez remember what we practiced bro yeah oh i know
i'm falling i'm just running everywhere and holding f on
every wall i see i'm just don't reinforce in between sites
because it provides no utility to our team yeah i'm gonna do
that i'm gonna do that
We can cross in here.
No, no.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna set it up now.
Oh, no, I canceled it.
I'm gonna do a little bit of this.
Yeah, there we go, bro.
Yeah.
And then we have this whole area to it, like, just to be
able to, to go in between.
All right.
I might have a barricade.
Where would they go?
Oh, come my way.
Come in my way.
Where's your way?
Oh, here?
Don't worry.
I'm showing a motion sensor.
I don't know.
This angle is insane.
Look at my angle.
Holy shit.
I can see the whole hallway from this up.
Oh, oh, they're over there.
I hear.
Oh, I see.
I see it.
Yeah, yeah.
Hold on.
I'll try to get some shit over there.
Nice shots.
Bye.
I'm throwing motion sets.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Wait, there's something.
There's just an over.
Oh, green gas.
He's wall banging behind it while being here.
Watch out.
I'm OTF.
That stands for on the flank.
Wait, really?
Oh, oh, what?
Oh, they threw a grenade at me.
I ain't even here.
Oh, me.
They're right inside that room.
Yeah.
I got this.
Oh, he's down.
He's down.
There's the guy down.
What?
No, I did the thing where I didn't switch to my weapon
again.
I pressed left click and it just made it click.
And then you wouldn't shoot.
One minute remaining.
Wait, one minute.
Oh, my God.
I didn't even look at the time.
Okay.
my fault this was my fault i should have deep flanked again
i will i will deep flank again behind you oh my god they're
all here oh behind us they're all here all right badger
they're all badger you're gonna kill their entire team you
have you see my motion sensor it's motion censoring they're
on b they're on b so they're gonna run out of b oh yeah good
try oh shit all right all right that was my fault i didn't
we had to do the deep flank again the deep flank okay we
can't we can't we can't be playing to their to their you
know you yeah guys we're like running into them again guys
we we're doing what i would have killed all of them but when
i use my gas launcher and i don't switch to my gun it looks
like i have my gun out but i still have my gas launcher
selected so when i press left click it just makes a click
sound and then i die
i forgot to get the needs oh man okay it's fine get all the
way oh wait where do you need nades i brought nades no i
just forgot to grab nades in general okay okay never mind
fine all right we just gotta do the flank again the deep the
deep planks shoot them in a like we'll board up the site
then just be around site and then shoot them in their butt
there's more room this way so they're probably gonna come
this way breaking this breaking this floor bring this
i'm gonna put a wall like this put a wall like this I don't
know where they're gonna be coming I'm scared we just have
to wait they're coming west oh my god oh my god they can
shoot me yeah no fucking shit they can't I'm not used to
this oh my god badger you are crazy Oh, I'm flashed.
I got him.
How did you get over there?
Oh, you went this way.
Wait, wait.
They're over here.
I see him.
I put a motion sensor here.
You see it?
Over here.
They were crouching.
I'm fucking stupid.
They were crouching in the corner.
They're in this corner.
They're all here.
One is one HP.
Nice.
Huge.
Dirt.
Dirt's planning.
Hold on.
Oh, that guy's one shot.
Nice.
Oh, he got him.
Oh, boom.
Wait, he's safe.
Oh, last one is melee, melee, melee.
Okay, you guys got.
Oh, no.
Do you want it or ask for you?
You want it or I need all charge.
So like, I'll take it.
The fire.
We're dying.
Holy shit.
It's true.
There was a lot in there.
So I can watch out.
You can't kill me on the portal right now.
I'm actually invincible.
You cannot kill me in a way that matters.
I am.
Do you really know what you do?
They have like three stacked on top of each other and I was
just throwing impact nades.
And then Gomez walked into my gas launcher and killed
himself.
Wait, did you kill me?
Yes.
There's friendly fire.
Of course there is.
Oh, wait, no.
I thought I got shot.
That was the gas.
No, you went into my gas.
Literally.
Yes.
dude I ran into the fart cloud and I got shot it wasn't even
like I shot you and then like like I shot into you you
literally ran into my gas yourself I did okay I didn't know
I didn't I didn't think about it yeah you definitely were
not thinking I will agree with that oh I clearly wasn't
although the barricades are shared yeah so basically you
have to hoard the Barricades and barricade what you want to
barricade before other people barricade what they want to
barricade I've just been barricading the same spot over I
was too many words Guys I think they're gonna switch it up
this time get ready They might go flank hunting So I might
get shot trying to flank because they're flanking the flank
You're foam wall now Oh you hear that coming in my way
Where's your way oh that way They're coming in my way for
sure i got motion i got motion oh did you guys see that
they're throwing grenades at me i'm getting out of here
batman i had a fucking whoa bang disaster whoa i don't have
another motion i got timing i got timing which point they go
through this vent so i got this i'm a little scared
oh they're lurking very slowly guys that's because they
don't want me to shoot them in the back so now they're like
they're playing real slow and like watching i think coming
my way yep yeah there's a bunch coming my way they flashbang
coming in my way too i can't see anything i can't see it's a
guy with a big thing one minute remaining a shield sorry i
forgot the word a big thing i'm just drop dropping some
altos we just have to wait we don't have to do i do not have
nades i do not have nades there's a bunch right here right
on my x right on my x they bought the shield is one hp the
shield is literally one hp oh my god and i was one hp i was
yeah you got this you got winnable what's going you guys
gotta play very patient 30 seconds got him 2v2 situation one
v1 one v1 oh one v1 motion there's motion there's motion he
might not have right right in front of us in the plant oh he
got rid of my motion He got rid of my emotion.
He got rid of it.
Just crouch.
Don't even engage him.
10 seconds.
Wait, just...
Oh!
That's so close.
I couldn't hear.
I couldn't hear the barbed wire.
I was trying to run around until I was forced to plant.
That's why.
We're on attack now.
Attack, attack, attack, attack.
Attack, attack, attack.
No one got that.
He wouldn't kill.
We got this, guys.
We got this.
I got my smoke grenades.
did they ever actually like how you can pick the character
and swap to it if you see the point i like it because i kind
of want i maybe want to go this the stim guy didn't they
make us all like have a sentence or something like a catch
yeah i think they displayed it when we won the last round
did you do i hope they displayed mine bro i hope mine was
mine was eat chicken did you yours was not eat chicken no
that's not true mine is too easy what is yours are right
over here let me find something that is very acceptable for
this line no badger's line is great bro too easy it's like
that's a hard one you know especially if you say it in the
nerd voice too like too easy sure four one was was a lot it
was he submitted a paragraph wait let's not go into it he
says it wait wait what is it bro come on i would have to
bring it up but doki has to read it wait why do i have to
read it team captain bro Why they think they think they had
motion right here.
I'm rotating wait I forgot what mine was.
I think it was like something about being alpha
What's the plan?
I forgot what our plan was Oh, I don't know.
We didn't have one.
It's the same plan as always.
Okay, okay.
That's cool.
You don't need no plan.
You know, they all went together.
We didn't have my gun out.
It's a good thing.
I didn't see anyone Hey, so you know, sure for watch out.
There's a there's a There we go.
Phone deployed.
Camera's live.
I don't see anyone in there.
Okay.
Is that our motion sensor or their motion?
Their motion sensor.
Yo, huge motion.
I got one.
Huge motion.
Breaking the walls.
That's their motion.
Where?
I need motion.
Throw a thing.
Throw a thing over there.
I got motion.
No, you.
I have another one.
Okay.
You can throw it up.
You can throw shit up.
Yeah, I know.
Oh, my bad twin.
You got it.
Oh, we have.
Oh, my bad twin.
You still got it.
Motion, motion.
Yeah, they're in that little room.
I can't run by.
I don't have.
Oh, I have a need.
They're still.
I bet not going to run by.
Yeah.
Okay.
We have 30 seconds.
I'm covering it.
Hold on.
I'm throwing a wall on the side on the right.
Okay, now we have right covered breaking this wall.
I got one.
They're in B.
They're in B They're in B.
There's one.
There's a guy here.
There's a shotgun.
You shot me!
I got him.
I'm planting.
I'm going.
Oh, shotgun.
Damn it.
Shuffle kill him.
Oh, on the X.
We guys run in.
Run in.
You guys need to run in.
He's down.
You gotta defuse.
Get the bomb.
Get the bomb right here.
20 y'all shot me in the back who is screaming to grab the
bomb when we're on offense oh yeah gomez i dropped it i died
how much time was left 10 seconds like 10 seconds three
seconds yeah we need to kill him i don't think we had enough
time to plant that unless there's an overtime way you're
right we should just go before he's like do not ever plant
the bomb ever Gomez baited us, basically.
But the point, or the...
Yeah, but you baited us.
I dropped the bomb.
Someone else grabbed the bomb.
You're outskirts.
I wasted too many walls, so I can wall myself.
I'm so sorry.
I got my one.
That's what matters.
Yeah, me too.
I got my one.
Someone did not get their one.
Someone got double shotgun in the face.
This was the first round.
I did get my one.
I'm not going to have two and three.
I'm so sorry.
I let y'all know.
Guys, if they win the next next one, we're out.
I love you so much for me.
That's pretty true.
Yeah, that's true.
Who gave me back the bomb?
That's true.
Yeah, that's true.
Oh my god.
No, that's true.
It's actually true.
Heading over.
Yeah, that's true.
I'm heading over to sure for it.
I have the bomb.
Why can I jump through this?
Oh, dokey, you are the bomb.
Damn.
That was oddly wholesome.
Mine.
No, does the blue grenade on the black guy with the weird
haircut, does that do damage?
Yes, that's like it's like there's no we denial.
Oh, spicy.
Okay, where is the where is it?
Okay, it's over here.
Okay, you shot.
Oh, corner camping.
He's right there through the I fucked up my motion.
If this guy peeks me, he's dead.
They are so dead.
Can you destroy motion sensors?
Yeah, you can melee.
You shoot it or yeah, you shoot it.
And you can shoot it.
You have to melee it.
Do you have to crouch shoot it or how?
Uh, I think someone's got a shotgun in there.
You have to shoot at the ground.
Oh, you see that motion sensor?
I was right.
Nice badger.
Yep.
You're looking, I'm so sorry for your motion sensor.
What did you do to my motion sensor?
Blowing that hole up.
You should basically.
Motion sensor deployed.
I threw another motion sensor.
Oh, behind me oh there was a lurker i have the bomb by the
way there's no way that shotgun is that strong goodbye sure
poor how did that miss yeah i was like he just shot you
across the map hold on we not we might be sleeping on that
on defense wait hey badger wait what's your plan to win i
have to sprint across the map if they or it's all good die
all right guys i don't think i would be able to get to the
bomb unless you're one before it you could have one before
it you know oh sorry one two we'll take it bro we'll take it
we'll take it oh and two yeah i got in their heads that one
round and then they said all right open dokey street i don't
even think we had a plan and attack guys i
your one yeah i won my one someone didn't win their ones it
was me i got corner look at the stats bro i barely got a
kill bro oh oh it's okay it's all boring about today's round
robin day i had two very unfortunate deaths what happened
well like i said one of them if you use your util and then
oh yeah it'll have your util out and not shoot your gun
Yeah, we could have won that round if you had your U-Till.
Mm-hmm.
No, if I didn't have my U-Till after I had already used it.
I wonder what the stats are on the other teams.
If we have...
I'll agree.
Are you asking me about...
Okay, please select a side for round three against team...
Wait.
oh uh do we want defense again what do you want defense the
last team last team of the day defense all right
all right defense again wait oh you're not done against
these guys oh wait are we one one no we're we're playing
against the 13 yeah i was like oh okay losers we're talking
about We're freaking, freaking losers, man.
Why you got to keep bringing it up?
I'm trying to keep the morale up, man.
Why are you keeping your morale up and you bring up the fact
that we're losing?
They freaking kicked us on the ground.
You're putting dirt in our face, man.
You were supposed to carry, Gomez.
What's the point of being level nine?
I can't say anything.
I'm being bullied.
yeah anyway guys feel free to thank you again to punchy
blind spot for the sponsor uh feel free to check out click
the link pin in the chat or in the description below or
check out the main broadcast of the main broadcast on twitch
guys it's just so hard it's just so much different your
punishment is playing rocket raccoon for the day after.
Oh, okay.
No, no, I'm not doing that.
No, I was like, I, I did that for like two weeks.
You truly want our forgiveness.
That's what you must do.
Yeah, that must, you must do that.
Oh, actually, you know what?
Sure, for us, since you haven't played the game at all, I
was playing on Rocket for like two weeks straight, and I got
to the point where I started like VPS rocketing, and I, and
I was like climbing.
I started climbing again.
It was pretty, it was pretty fun.
Why were you playing Rocket for two weeks straight?
yeah i wish you did yourself because it's either it's either
triple support and i have to go with third support or or i
have three deep or four dps players on my team and i have to
get i have to play support it sucks see what i do and just
like play flank adam and then watch everything unfold around
you the lot what's your win rate on that you know he can fly
now i had like a 75 win rate on it and people were crashing
out
You can do that now because he can fly now.
Yeah, he can fly.
You can flank.
It's right.
You're not playing it for that.
He doesn't want to go through triple support.
He doesn't want fucking go against triple support.
No, no, no, no, no.
But he doesn't understand.
If he picks Adam, they're going to think he's running triple
support, but then he's actually on the flank.
So he's just another DPS.
What's going to happen is I'm going to pick Adam, then we're
going to have one other support and then they go, what the
hell dude?
Are Adam is flanking?
Bro.
no no no you trust me just if there's a if there's a game
with two supports already just pick out them you you like
bait them so hard think about it you can you can mind-boggle
them if you just if you just play into their mind into their
mindset i don't think so waves my finger no no he doesn't
want to do that i'd rather play dead walk we're playing
deadlock i feel like you played the the guy with the pillow
rem i play him sometimes no he does like he does what he
plays he plays like all the new characters right who's the
best out of all the new characters uh silver probably i
thought she had like a shitty ass win rate on launch no
there's no way there's no way you're not playing ram i
should say you character but that is a new character Celeste
is not stronger than Silver.
That's Cap.
Who said that?
My chat.
You're streaming.
I don't even know that.
What do you mean?
Dude, I'm just so used to having a movie in Russian, just
not streaming.
So I thought, I was like, oh, you know, those two, those two
are not streaming.
Surefire is not going to stream.
Oh, he's streaming.
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
I mean, streaming versus not streaming is really just a
choice between whether you want to be live on the internet
or not.
I mean, what do you?
Yeah.
It's an old choice at the end of the day.
So Super Gomez, do you play a lot of...
I'll interrupt or what do you play?
I play a lot of Overwatch.
I used to play a lot of Overwatch, and then I played a lot
of rivals.
Overwatch?
Yeah.
You know, me and Shorfour used to be together when we were
on Sentinels, but now it's just him, right?
Since he's the only one signed in it.
No, they picked up a new team.
used to yeah they did pick up a new team yeah but me and him
like we're skipping together holding hands and shit and you
know this guy decided to leave rivals you said that he said
that that decision ever oh he was saying how you and you and
gomez are like bffs when you guys were in sentinel is that
true sure for you guys hang out yeah remember that game we
had when i was on wolverine yeah you know i was on he's like
you see that guy up there i'm gonna jump him and then he
jumped him yeah i literally grabbed an iron man all this
guy's wolverine yeah and my testosterone was like so high
from it i was like oh i just did that that's what i'm sure
let's get them two levels back to normal he's getting a
little too excited there no i was impressed to myself i was
like if i mess this up all my all my recognition for him is
gone cool i was gonna get booted to the to the ground like
all of his other duos where he just leaves them in the dirt.
Hmm?
I don't do.
I know.
You denied me.
What do you mean by all my other duos?
It's just me.
Oh.
Maybe not feel special, man.
Because you're not.
Fuck you.
Why do you say that?
What do you mean?
I can't handle this music anymore.
It's looping.
Oh, that's a PUBG.
I cut it off as soon as I booted up the game.
So Gomez and SureForbes play video games for money.
That's crazy.
Don't you technically play for money, Badger?
Making you good videos are for money.
You're good at video games for money.
Not like you play them or you fool around and talk about
them for money.
It's different.
Technically, technically Russian Badger, I'm unemployed at
the moment.
We got a new...
Well, we're all unemployed, so that's not saying much.
Yes, okay.
What's up?
New code, by the way.
New code.
What?
I have a bad wrist, so I'm waiting to get that fixed.
Yes, I'm playing with a bad wrist right now.
It's not fun, but it's also not that bad.
Surprisingly.
Not too bad, not too shabby.
You guys are all super young, too.
You guys are real zoomers.
You got like two at the beginning of the year that you were
born.
I'm 30.
wait when but whenever i say i'm 22 people call me old as
133 so i still feel old oh my god hag hey man what yes i am
hey man chill out with all that name calling wait wait wait
i'm about you 34 bro i've been 34 for the past five years oh
my gosh and how long were you 34 Hey, relax for me, all
right?
I only got like 19 gray hairs right now.
Once it hits 20, I'm giving up and dying at all.
Why you calling it a day?
I'm in the retirement home right now.
Just shave the head.
But now the retirement, the...
Hell, no, I'm not having a built nut head.
Gomez, you're on the attack side.
Come back here.
Also, we're missing Shure 4.
Yeah, hold on.
Oh.
I didn't know there was a new lobby yet.
Yeah, it's a new lobby.
where city we're playing what map are we on we're on why is
this at all the all one hospital you're just like jenna
you're just like uh jennifer lawrence did no hard feelings i
was i was 29 two years ago i'm 32 32.
you're please press ready we are ready man like I'm 21 plus
that's what my mom says all like all of you are older than
me and I have wrist issues at 22 that's on you that's on you
yeah 22 you're like a little toddler you don't even
understand do I sound 22 to you all right Gomez ready up by
the way I'm writing up I don't know because every person
that I've talked to I think I I've been like mid 30s or like
early 30s mid 30s I mean you broke you I mean your bones are
like mid 30s at that point she just called you broke
straight oh yeah she just called broke i heard that no i
said your bones your bones you've changed you got no motion
and your bones are broken
i'm broken i don't have working limbs oh oh okay at least
you have insurance right
guys it's the last match of the day silence
in 20 26 you think i have insurance oh what are you gonna do
about that we're gonna lock in i'm good the only people the
only people that have any kind of insurance apparently we
are we are showing up for day two because we are not last
apparently so awesome yes i can shoot whoever i want in my
team now oh i forgot to get the i forgot to get the the name
Who got lost?
They just not told us.
Is it Lily Peach's team?
I dropped my grenade.
Can I pick that back up?
Oh, I can't.
Once I drop it, it's drop.
It's over.
When I drop up a live grenade.
Dude, is this live?
Not my grenade.
I'm at my C4 charge.
I dropped my C4 is what I'm going to say.
Me when I set forth a chemical reaction that cannot be
stopped.
Dude, how do I stop this?
Dude, how do I turn off the bomb when it's bombing?
Guys, the pins up.
Can someone insert their finger?
Okay, I'm here in Stuff West.
I'm here in Stuff West.
I'm East, though.
Foam wall now.
Wait.
Motion?
They broke up from the wall over here.
I don't know how to ping.
It's Z or X.
Oh my god, I'm dead.
Wait, I'm throwing motion for you.
Fulting.
Okay, you were blocking me, so I couldn't throw the motion.
Oh, I can't.
I'm no motion.
I'm reloading.
There's one over.
Oh, my God.
There's one here.
There's one over here.
Oh, they're on, they're on site, they're on A.
They're over here.
They're on point situation.
Is it 2v3.
Oh, my God, they were all here with the H1.
Oh, they are.
No, no, there was another person that was holding that
angle.
there was another person that was holding an angle that was
right now you were so fucking uh vulnerable there i thought
they were gonna i thought they were gonna coordinate on me
at the same time remaining i didn't even know that was i
didn't know that planted the bomb but not pager i trust you
heavenly oh that's our side pets up right there oh my god
they're all there you see them you Oh my god.
Oh, they didn't see me.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I was gonna say I'm pretty sure he saw you.
I hit control instead of C because I'm old.
So I didn't crouch under the desk.
I aimed down.
Yeah, yeah.
I rebinded all that.
I rebinded my desk control.
I actually had an old man moment.
I might.
Yeah, I'm rebinding right now.
That actually got me killed.
I'm surprised he didn't.
That actually pushed me off.
Oh my god, bro.
C is like how you crouch your aim.
Yes.
Yeah.
I was trying to crouch under the desk to not get shot, bro.
all right i've got my stuff now here we go bro wait move out
of the way oh my machine coming man you know we've got the
plan you know i'll be i'll be a forehand and you will hunt
worth breaking oh my god you remind me i'm gonna i'm
reinforcing this door if no one objects.
Actually, no.
If we're dead, because, yeah, I'm actually now I'm going to
reinforce it.
Because somebody's going to object and it's going to
reinforce this door.
They cracked your stream open, boss.
But it's over.
Like, they're watching you.
Like, it's over.
All right, Gomez, I see that.
Yeah, or are you doing the damn queen?
The what?
The queen theme, that song.
We will, we will rock you.
I'm coaching.
Someone was doing that beef.
was doing that b oh oh they're all over here there is
someone on the right side lord had us if you break that wall
with your impact i bet you kill one never mind my motion's
gone by the way huge
oh my god they're breaking this wall they're breaking this
wall okay
good part good Good shit.
Oh, that was my bad.
Okay, they used all their flashes.
Oh, they broke the wall.
Boom incoming.
Yogi, you are putting yourself out in the open.
Oh, I shouldn't have done that.
Got one.
Ah, I got downed.
Oh, I'm downed.
Wait, what?
Here, I'll try to go to the safe space.
I wonder if I can save you.
Oh, no, they followed me.
Never mind.
You can try, sure, for but there's at least one watch.
One point.
in the corner right here oh baited no okay good shit where
is it 101 101 oh they're both right here wait where are they
how did they plant and then instantly oh my god oh i didn't
know where they are they're both right there yeah guys
they're playing really quiet yeah they're playing very slow
location so they have a flanker who's like flank hunting so
i was hunting him and then i that's okay i thought you got
shot in the back there's a guy playing the the headdress i
was like hunting him and i was like i don't care anymore so
you're the reason why we all died right my bad bro i'll re
actually gonna have to play slow i guess they're playing
very slow they're playing very very slow so we play faster
foam wall now i just foam wall now foam wall i got your
hands trace the grove and shake your pants y'all we know
this game has spawn protection it will show your it will
show yourself you're outside all right wait i can't just aim
through the window yeah you can't do that yeah you just show
whoever it comes around this corner yeah oh they're coming
to our left i hear them coming through the same way uh if
you look on your map you get cardinal directions oh i just
bought it i got some damage in nice trust you oh they they
flashed they're they're they're peeling you heavenly hold on
okay it's okay you're okay i'm all in us here here nice all
right i'm going around i'm going around i'm going around
oh bro i told you the plan is good we just got to give them
some than to look at it.
Good fight.
Oh, that guy's that guy's one.
How did he not die?
No, the fuse.
Is it right here?
The fuse right here.
Oh, they had an angle.
Oh, I could see this is his head.
Well, why don't there's one shot?
Like, what do we?
What's behind us?
What do we want to show?
You know I'm here.
They know I'm here.
I got one.
That was the one shot.
I got two.
Oh my God.
Go my double.
One left.
Uno mass.
I was bait.
Okay.
We're attacked now.
We're attacked.
I think we got this, guys.
We can do it.
I thought it was like line of sight where you have to get
hit by it, but I think it has to be on top of you.
It has to be on top of you.
Oh, I see.
Like an alien.
And then their whole, getting flash by it is really bad
though, because your whole screen is black.
It gives you like two inches of a sight.
Wow.
I have a little secret.
You can see, for some reason, you can see their bullets,
like from their gun.
Like the, the, the, the flash muzzle from the gun.
So I just, I just look at whatever is shot.
The tracers?
Like the, you know, the, you know, like the muzzle flash.
Like the muzzle flash.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
For some reason you can see it.
I don't think it's intentional, but it's, you can see it.
that's cool all right what's the plan what what's on here
the plan is when you're one if we're on the main screen and
i get like killed the announcers have to call me headass oh
my god you see that guy that was there what the one front
left gomez yeah i got it hold on one there's a guy right
here that guy the ball watching that what the frick is
there's someone over there lord yes yeah there is I got him.
I got him.
He was in the corner.
You got him.
There you go.
There you see it.
My motion worked.
Oh, my.
Oh, he's right here.
Right behind you.
In that room.
Nice.
Gotcha, bitch.
You can't shoot the fucking barbed wire.
No, you just punch it.
Motion.
You don't even need to shoot that barbed wire.
You're good.
I got my ones.
Oh, shit.
There's another one.
Here.
I got them.
There's only two left.
I'm reloading my pistol.
One here.
Oh, should they see me?
He's on point.
Are you here?
I'll try to get him with an aid.
I think he ran past an aid.
Hold on.
Don't touch that.
That hurts you.
I know.
Don't hurt you.
Boom wall now.
That's it.
Plant it.
Bomb wall now.
Now.
Get here.
Help me.
Oh, yeah.
I got worried, man.
I got worried.
I got so scared.
You turn around and you are like, the guy with the shotgun.
He's traumatized, bro.
He's got PTSD on shotguns.
It's like war never changes.
You didn't see it.
He was shooting shots above me.
That shit was whizzing above me.
Yeah.
And then you turn around and you look at me directly out of
the barrel i can't engage him it's a doorway dude he's like
looking at your own team and being like who do i want to die
by him as you like are looking into my a cock like dude this
is not helping be like look in rivals you don't have to deal
with getting your teammates to shoot you yeah but yet this
is not rivals yeah don't worry about your support shooting
you yeah and usually oh god oh yeah i didn't even remember i
just thought about the shooting part Oh, I hate Super Go has
got to be my favorite GF player.
Probably my top five favorite GF player all time.
Holy shit.
Wait, they broke the, they broke this door.
I'm cooking.
I'm motioning this.
Oh, they spawn peeking.
Yo, we win these.
We win these.
Oh, they know we're here.
Dante Bayou.
I have an idea.
So I'm going to do this.
Oh my God, they are.
I'm going to put that there.
What was the point of that?
Lightning.
Mining.
I got him.
I got one.
Yo, yo, run out.
There's one more over here.
One more over here.
I missed!
Grenade!
I got you.
Don't worry.
He's right there.
I'm dead.
Oh, there's like three in there, Ducky.
There's like, don't go that way.
Just don't go that way.
This thing works half the time and doesn't work the other
half.
No, I couldn't do anything.
Did you put your safety on?
No, I wasn't meant to reload.
I was a habit.
It's a sow.
I know!
I got the accident of reload.
you still think she's got two bullets in the saw you just
got one tapped why i have ptsd you know what don't give me
that character bro no don't don't give me no it was the one
time the one time i could have pressured brought my shotgun
out i get panicked you know i'm gonna whistle look i got my
one i got my one He was like, what?
I forget if this is the first match or the second or third.
This is the first.
This is the first one.
This is our very first one.
This sniper lady works half the time and doesn't work the
other half.
Maybe you're missing.
I don't, I don't need the bomb.
The little line is going through them.
We just picking up the bomb.
Someone gonna pick up the bomb?
Nah.
I got it.
How do you even pick up the bomb?
You hit G, it shows the bottom of the screen.
How do you plant?
What's the plant button?
F.
All right, I'll walk in and press F.
I'm curious now, how many bullets did you have in your mag?
Motion sensor deployed.
When you reloaded your big-ass gun, Doki.
I don't know.
It was by reflex.
Oh.
It was reflex when I did it.
By the way, I'm taking the long way.
I'm taking the Uber long way.
Oh, my God.
I knew someone was fucking lurking.
reloading now holy barbed wire just don't go that way heaven
yeah i'm not i'm just throwing grenade just because i'm
angry at them takes so many oh my god he's crouching i'm
scared are you guys in already no the guy that's crouching
and trying to kill me
scan two he's around that corner i hit him once okay i have
an idea smoke motion break this oh oh you see that enemies
here oh one me badging oh i got timing i got timing okay
nice i don't have no more motion oh he's here i got my one
though i got my one
it's not a mentality no it's not it's not wait sure for us
one kill someone oh has been dropped oh he's in that corner
oh these lines don't work
oh sure for wasn't winning his ones i have a hundred and
twenty nine pings yeah you do What the fuck?
Wait, no shit, no shit I'm getting shot around corners.
Damn.
I thought it was fine.
Yes, you're not.
It's okay, we still have a click.
Okay, do you want map?
I don't think the sniper is very good on the hospital map.
Okay, you want to pick the, what was it?
What was the hub again?
I don't remember what it was called.
Third hub?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Back to third hub B.
Wait, no, it's a B.
Yeah, yeah, third hub B.
Yeah.
All right, this is it.
This is where we make a comeback.
Okay.
Sorry, I was typing someone.
Everyone ready up.
Guys, we cannot give up the mentality here.
If we ready up now, we have the...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We have the reassurance.
They think that we're tilted.
No, we're not.
Who said we were tilted?
Yeah, who said we were tilted?
No, they think we're tilted.
We're not, though.
That's the thing.
That's true.
They think we are.
Also, sorry, I had sure for a stream of, sure for a, did you
go one and six?
Yeah.
He's not ashamed of that.
I had my op and I shot them.
That's not a positive mentality, by the way.
Along with I got my one is not going to win us games.
It's just not.
It's not going to work.
I love this team, man.
I mean, shoot the op, bullet line, go through, not die.
question mark also i i think we are supposed to yeah we're
split we're in attack oh we're yeah because what are their
teammates swap we can't okay so they gotta scoot over to
cancel them ready yeah yeah cancel ready got scoot scoot
over somebody's got to go to observer we're coming badger
come on over oh wait no subros is still on the yeah
somebody's still in my spot his name is subrosa get his ass
out right now come on team captain get out of here
can somebody get this bing bong bazango bing bong burger out
of the attack team please i think oh he's out he's out there
we go i welcome back to the team oh yeah yeah yeah ready up
guys they said please our last game or second last game
depending on how this goes no we got this team we got this
we got i believe i believe number one have had kills but i
had damage how and how much damage was that i don't know i
forget so how do you know you had damage then if you forgot
wait because i know you have one kill wait you had one kill
hold on hold on oh my god they added me specifically okay if
you had one kill right and had six deaths usually every shot
that you that you hit them with and downs them so on every
round i was the sniper oh what the were you doing shoot i
thought you were on sniper the whole time i can't on defense
i'm the gas yeah defense you don't get sniper no sniper i
want to play sniper on defense i feel like that's that
sounds op you're not allowed you can only play it on attack
Yeah, we're on attack, you know, I just realized.
I'm going to snip everyone.
Actually, you know what?
No.
I'm gonna go shield.
I'm going Wilson.
It's a little too close to another name.
But I got it.
I believe it is.
And everyone's going to walk in with me, okay?
Everyone's going to walk in with me.
We're going to kill them, okay?
Okay, but where are you going?
I'm going...
I can't wait to see you get lit on fire.
No, I won't.
I don't think you should... I don't think you should hold
the bomb then.
Oh, Schirfer's not coming with us.
I'm OTA.
That guy's a loner.
It's okay.
We're a team, guys.
What happened?
I thought we were a team.
Yo, I don't want to hear that shit, Doki.
You literally just said I got my one.
You guys suck.
I don't want to hear that.
I didn't say the last part.
That's an assumption.
I said I got my one.
I was very happy that I got my one.
It was up to you guys to get your other ones.
What is our strategies?
What happened to our strategy?
motion oh my god why did you set okay gooper somas is going
in our health will stay above zero their health will hit
zero my motion oh my god oh my god i countered him i
reframed you it's all good it's all good it's all good so
you're telling me i checked corner and it doesn't show him
here here let's revive let's let keep going keep going keep
going you're an easy target keep crawling i don't know why
dokey didn't win that one she keeps talking about i don't
want to live enough for that
Really?
Yo, my fault gang.
My fault gang.
Oh my god.
That guy's got a shotgun.
And then there was one.
He's got a shotgun.
That's a real deluge.
Who's a range though?
I can't wait to try that shotgun.
Oh my god.
I did.
If you can see a shotgun, it should kill you.
I can't wait to try it out.
I want to try it out so bad.
How am I supposed to get through here?
You shoot the...
You can just melee the foam.
You have a scan.
Shoot it.
Melee it.
You can go outside and go get the go.
like so many choices wouldn't be funny if you guys shot from
behind though they're pretty funny nah you guys aren't nerdy
enough that would never help that paint looks like weight
paint and blender it does look like it's been pissing me off
a little bit damn did they have one crouch or one standing
up oh my god that was supposed to do that that was true also
how do they know to look in that one specific direction on
our communication around revo heard you i felt like i
realized yeah yeah i feel like there was something going on
there i was across the match i feel i feel like something
weird was going on there badger i was slamming this out of
my pink cotton candy foam wall how did they know i was
coming now it's way over there who was making those noises
i'm going in outskirts i'm pushing i'm going i'm i'm
dividing i want to be far away from heavenly as possible bro
you keep talking about these ones i'm like Why did you
destroy my cover?
Why did you destroy my cover?
That's unfair.
That's cheating.
He didn't have cover.
You did.
You're cheating.
Win the one.
Not the one with cover.
I'm so excited to play this again tomorrow.
I'm so excited to play with this team tomorrow, guys.
We're family.
In this right now, I'm like, run it back.
Please.
All right.
We're just rushing straight in there.
Don't even think, bro.
Yeah, bullet open.
All right.
two one okay stimming go go i'm going in that's a it's a c4
by the way what the is going on over here running it i gotta
get out no i just they have a name he left he left all right
guys we gotta we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna the bomb
down that's a bit more than it i can't why did you run in
front of my I can't make it to the bomb before he refuses
it.
Get to me, get to me, get to me, get to me.
It's reinforced up.
Just go around.
He's defusing.
Oh my God, Shreve.
He's right here.
He's on it.
He's defusing.
Get in the ass.
Woo, we did it.
We only had to have one AFK to win.
wait it's really a 4v5 i'm so glad you guys didn't see that
i tried to wall bang someone and doki ran in front of me and
i fucking gunned her down i was so zoomed in i didn't even
know she was in my lms okay that's like how did doki die
wait me holding an arctic warfare super magnum sniper rifle
i can zoom i can zoom really far so i read a wall bang
someone i saw and then i was like oh i got someone because i
saw the red little icon and i zoomed back out and i see on
the ground oh wait i'm the wrong start you were like i got
my one and the one was me dog you saw the atoms in the back
of yokey's head and then pulled the trigger all right i got
my stim ready to go i got my stim So are we waiting it out
or just go play 4v5 like well, it's a hard.
It's a defensive advantage I guess so I mean, I mean, you
guys can do whatever you want.
I'm playing games.
Oh my god.
Oh my god You I'm not I got one Nice Nice, nice.
It's a 4v5 now I mean, you guys can do whatever you want.
I'm killing.
I'm not standing in front of sure for I'm going another way
I have your I have your heroine shot right here I'm just
going in.
Oh, I'm just going in.
I'm just going in.
Oh, I got the blue thing.
Get out of the blue thing, dude.
Hey, man.
Pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
Okay.
I got two.
Nice.
Oh, shoot behind me.
Right here.
Flanking right here.
Oh, you there.
Where's the bomb?
This was short for it.
What the fuck?
He's short for fighting his life right now.
Oh, he's right there.
Okay, nice.
Okay, sorry.
Sorry.
What are you saying?
Well done.
No, I was just watching you because I was like, how are you
gonna kill me?
I don't think the sniper is 100% accurate.
It's not.
What?
Yes, it's a shotgun.
Wait, did you think it was?
It's a sniper that isn't 100% accurate.
No wonder I've been missing it.
Wait, you didn't even notice that?
Yeah, I noticed because I've been missing.
It's because we've been gaslighting.
Maybe we didn't hit your shots, bro, maybe.
You're not, I promise you're not asked.
The sniper is just not 100.
That's fucked!
It's a one shot and then I have to bolt it.
What do you mean?
It's just fucking random R&D that it just fucking not hit
him.
Shoot Doki again.
It hits her.
Yeah, it barely hits me though.
It's only accurate when you're friendly fire.
Wait, did you say R&D or R&G?
R&G is research and development.
I thought you said RTE Doki.
Yeah.
How do I put this ball?
Kind of like, I can rotate it.
Can you see me spinning it?
All right, all right.
Here we go.
Oh, I was gonna.
One in a minute.
Mindset.
Don't worry.
I got motioning is...
You guys are barricading shit.
We still got seven barricades.
I never barricaded one.
I barricaded one.
Coming in east.
Where's east?
A lot of this is not reinforced.
There's people over here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hold that angle.
Hold that.
Hold that hallway.
I got you.
But there's people on Gomez?
Or where?
Oh, okay.
Don't worry.
I have I have.
Oh, I see him.
I see him right here.
Right here.
Watch out It's right there.
Motion detector motion.
Okay, badger.
Okay.
I hit short force head.
Nothing.
Don't they're over by you.
I'm trying to pin them.
I'll try to pin them.
I'll go around.
This Glock got a switch, baby.
They still need Nintendo.
You got it.
Oh, it's coming to be there.
Okay, they're blowing and they're coming.
I'm coming.
Oh, my motion.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Got my one.
I'm just in.
I'm just.
Gomez team killed me.
Are you evil?
Are you in?
No, I didn't.
I didn't shoot.
Are you a bad guy?
No.
He's Gomez.
Problematic media?
Yeah, right here.
Watch out.
I'm, I just, I misfired.
Watch this.
See, look, I got the kill.
No, that was mine!
See, look.
Yay!
The petition to report and ban this team killer?
Yeah, this team killer?
No, no, no.
Vote kick, vote kick!
You say evil.
Did you say evil with a B?
Yeah.
Evil.
I'm not an evil person.
I call for a vote kick right now.
No, okay, here, here, here.
How about this?
I'll run out.
I'll run out in the open.
out in the open okay yeah we'll run out in the open and i'll
you might win i'll give us info okay you might win just give
me a shot yeah yeah i believe i'm doing it i'm doing that
i'm going all the way around he's gonna get he's gonna get
he's not gonna win man he's gonna get shotgun you might win
though see my windows yeah i don't know i feel like they get
shotgun i got this your first style was holding a sniper
that's not sure first style i got this
Is he got those?
I'm going out.
All right.
Trying to see where they are.
Oh.
Enemy's here.
Watch out.
I think they're going to kill him.
I think.
All right.
Now it's a flare fight.
There's a flare fight.
We got nobody on B.
Oh, that's not good.
That's for me shooting sure for.
It's okay.
Wait, they're heading to B.
I hear it.
Yo, who the hell was in charge of B-Sight?
I think it was.
Wait, wait.
Oh, here, here!
Enemies here!
Watch out!
Here!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my!
I smacked a lot of them, dude.
That was, yeah.
Remember the reloading gun?
They're like in the corner here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Doki Bird got your angle.
There you go.
Oh, I don't got that though.
Got one?
Okay, three, three.
I got one, too.
You can wait a minute.
You got 90 seconds.
Oh, that has the cover on someone Reaching the wall.
Hey, enemy's here.
Watch out There we go.
Oh, he's crawling.
Wait, what?
What?
Oh, I got shot from the No,
you should have just seen what happened when he did you just
should you should have just seen what he did There you do He
just he pulled like a fortnight and he just pumped someone
oh two people nice guys we did one of four before don't go
next to the person with the shotgun smirks so wait was that
a good job guys we won that five guys guys good job
everybody that counts that counts yes that count that's kind
of fucked up shouldn't have dc'd smirks
Is he even gonna come back?
Where is he?
Where did he go?
What happened to him?
I think his internet died or something.
Well, I gotta pee.
Alright, pee break.
I actually can't believe it.
I looked in this screenshot results area and it's...
They actually did put our ruin.
So it does count.
Of course it counts.
No, no.
i mean yes you gotta take your dubs when you can yes we
could fucking got that god we've fucking rolled them right
yeah yeah this is getting in between my tick tock time so uh
wait what's your tick tock time right now you're looking all
day yeah would you believe me that i don't even have it like
installed like i don't i have an account by I only use it
because my friend sent me shit.
Wait, why?
Because, does that mean there's so much better?
Order?
No, Sean!
No, Instagram.
Instagram is so much better.
Instagram?
You told me...
Yeah.
Who uses Instagram?
I only use it for the memes.
Only.
Like, if you...
Like, what else are you going to use Instagram for?
Like, what do you mean?
You tell me, suss emoji.
I thought only women used Instagram.
Also, I do watch YouTube shorts.
I do.
Is YouTube shorts as bad as TikTok?
I feel like it's same, isn't it?
Is it the same?
Someone said fat.
No, YouTube shorts.
What?
I feel like if you're racist, you use Instagram.
I feel like if, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's true.
That's pretty true.
That's true.
No, I'm not using it.
No, I am not.
That's true.
I'm not using it because of it.
We keep saying that's true, but it has to be true.
Look at this.
How about this?
Do you have an Instagram account, Badge?
Me?
No.
Of course not.
Why would I?
Me?
No, dude.
But look at any bio Instagram post.
Look at any bio Instagram post and open up the comment
section and it will be completely indecipherable.
You never have Instagram, no account, but you need Instagram
to look at Instagram, but talking about the cops no all
right here's my workaround it gets cross-posted to Twitter
and they show you the comment section on on Instagram and
that is why I do not download Instagram all right we're
gonna be at Hospital B yeah as map is Hospital B attack or
defense uh you know what defense why not what okay okay
never mind tag no no no okay okay attack on team guys
defense defense defense defense okay okay what if you guys
type it out then what if you guys type it in chat uh d d d e
okay type it type it defensive okay hold on i misspelled
that so bad oh wait i put in the wrong who did you type it
to who the fuck did you type it to this college discord that
i'm coaching i was in there for no reason all right then we
have to move over but whoops we have to move now you can't
all right i'm moving over yeah is it actually a 45 no no
it's a five they're back they're back yeah they came back
all right i feel like observer is kind of comfy right now
i'm in i'm in my observer i have a counterpoint you said
instagram users are racist but you just said that you use
twitter and i would say it but i'm going to i mean it's not
like twitter users can't also be racist.
I'm just saying that Instagram is racist.
I'm just saying that when she streams, she does bingo for
Instagram Reels.
Hey, let me tell you, every spot that says racism is always
in every stream.
That's, oh, it's checked in hard.
It's damn near a free space.
I mean, Grok did say he was Mecca.
I forgot to keep lobotomizing him.
They're not allowing it to be his true self.
you keep hitting them with anti-woke patches bro we gotta
fix them
i've never laughed like that before what the did i just do i
just i just heaved
and thank you again to pub g blind spot for today's sponsor
and tomorrow's sponsor because we're gonna be back for day
two guys another coke zero Day two.
No, it's actually a C4.
You guys can...
Oh, damn.
At 555 p.m.
on the Western Time Zone.
Click on the link in our chat or in the description below.
Thank you again for the sponsor.
I drink Coke Zero throughout the days.
How many Coke Zeros do you drink per day?
Do you know what's in C4?
Like two or three?
What's in it?
Do I know what's in C4?
300 milligrams of caffeine.
Things that make me happy.
Leave me alone.
Yes.
Vitamin B12.
that's just like a heart attack every time you're like
gambling on a heart attack just like drinking it but he
loves gambling just leave him alone some people can have
certain levels of caffeine take that compared to other
people some people can drink 600 milligrams of caffeine wait
another question 200 who drinks c4 me every day i've i've
never heard anyone you're the first person i've known that
that that drinks c4 well you need to get on that wave four
is pretty
oh whoops thank you my apologies we're getting yelled at
damn damn got called by the teacher oh my god they asked us
like two times to be like priest plus ready i was ready
though i was ready though not me we're just you're such an
idiot in chat this is so funny chat they can't see this
they're like are you ready for your match please press ready
game god it's always we're not streaming it we're watching
tiktoks in between the rounds like we're arguing about grok
to be fair i was waiting for them to switch sides yeah that
is true baby kids oh the shot i'm not playing shotgun guy
anymore you can have them i'm going back to my boy i like
kayak too much she's just oh no we're on shotgun guys just
something he's how i see myself bro like i wish i had a
robot arm
I believe in us but like old brain rotted I the first thing
that came up to me in my head was like the big bang theory
when Howard made like a robotic arm for himself oh yeah you
watch big bang theory like unironically like yeah because
I'm it fires hormones in my brain it's like that fire not
hormones no sorry not yeah yeah you're right you're at the
high IQ Yeah, it just the hormones.
It just like the hormones.
No, not hormones not that was the wrong word choice It was
wrong word choice I meant to I meant to give me dopamine
Dopamine I don't know Sheldon's kind of a beacon of
testosterone if you ask me they're breaking it in wait where
where Where don't don't worry.
I don't know how to Over there zero x zero x X's the ping.
I did it.
That's my ping.
Oh, there you go.
That door opened.
All right.
Okay, I'm gonna.
I got motion.
Oh, I'm stupid.
Holy, they were all over there.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
I got motion.
Oh, they've got first.
I did my flank wrong, my bad.
I'm a little scared here.
I have a shotgun.
They scan me.
Oh, he's one.
He's three.
Oh, my God.
I sprayed.
I got it.
Whoa, another one on me.
There's two over there.
No, they're both there.
They're through there.
All right.
Oh, my God.
There's one more over there.
Go through.
Watch out.
One ahead of you and one behind you.
Okay.
Where's the last guy?
You know where he is.
You can wait him out.
I guarantee it.
If you shoot this wall right now.
He's over to the right.
No!
No, you forgot the crowd.
Good try.
I got two though, at least.
I got one I got my two where are you I got my two I got one
and a half I got one I'm not gonna lie I had a 4v um also I
had a soda in my hand instead of my donut I got real thirsty
for a spray it was good though damn I'm so sad you're not
drinking gamer subs all times like just when you consume any
other beverage there's just trash I ran out of my
non-caffeinated ones and I'm not trying to bounce off the
walls in my big age all right well sure for just popped a c4
and a perk so he's ready and a molly i'm yeah yeah he's
locked he's locked guys i believe see i believe in you i
don't even know where they're gonna fucking i'm like only
percussed on in percussed molly percussed chase jay never
chase a woman rich never chase a associate where are they
gonna spawn though uh where does your grandmother's day.
We need to know.
Damn, she always got motion, dog.
Yeah, I always got the motion in the ocean.
Ooh, they're coming in out.
They're coming in west.
Dude, I'm detected by the enemy.
Oh, shit.
That's not good.
You're right, Conrad.
Oh, they busted.
I have motion.
I got something fire.
Over here.
i saw that lord house i saw it
wait my motion thing is gone motion sensor place i put
another motion oh yeah motion over here over here over here
over there
gas round fired oh huge gas huge gas oh my aim was so bad
because he's just running around in circles he just He was
literally just running in circles in there to tweak me out.
Yeah, that was a five.
Reload this thing?
I don't have no more motion, so good luck.
Oh, he has the stem.
Oh, shit!
Over here, over here, Badger.
One minute remaining.
I'm just trying not to get shot.
Hold on.
Nice.
2v2?
He's like right there.
Oh, my God.
Wait, never mind.
He's over there.
He's over here.
you were both right both causes right no no but no the the
bullet smoke is gonna be off there is someone in the smoke
okay nice give me one
yeah well done well done i'll make it up for you guys hold
on i'll make it up dude i didn't know i had two uses of my
gas grenade that's why it doesn't auto switch because you
can reload it
damn that's okay we're learning for day two you know the
tutorials tells you to press r right yeah but i can reload
my weapon but i think we're we're attacked now right i mean
anything that has a spare capacity can be reloaded it
doesn't say it has a spare it says one out of one yeah but
one out of one makes me think it's like you have one shot
you know it's kind of true though I should say like, don't,
don't get that.
That's true.
That's true and, uh, pretty true.
Yeah, that's pretty true.
Pretty true.
Any trues?
True and, yeah.
So I see barricades a bunch of random shit.
Where did they come from here again?
Yeah, here.
Motion sensor placed.
Setting wire.
Remote charge deployed.
Uh-oh.
Our entire area isn't barricaded.
Oh, no, we did not barricade here.
Oh, I hear gunshots.
We don't need to.
I hear a bunch of movement.
Me too.
Oh, right here.
Nice.
Oh, that guy's one shot.
You can you can.
Well, oh, no, you can't.
Oh, yes, you can.
Oh, wait.
You can't wall bang that.
Oh,
shit.
Oh, it was right here.
I was trying to throw my motion.
I got tired.
And no, that armor is crazy style 16 different ways It's my
they're all in that room to your right.
There's a bunch.
Oh, there's a bunch and they're all looking at you Why is
it?
This is it one before I came from you Gomez shot.
I'm gonna kill you.
What's up?
Wait, how?
Why is the woman that's just team killing?
How do I kill you?
Yeah, why is Gomez team killing everybody?
I was gonna aim at you guys Why is he?
It's fine, bro.
You know, it's okay.
aim my gun at you what happened bro what are you doing go
man i refuse to believe that i saw him i mean you can refuse
we saw it on the kill feed we i am so confused you can be in
denial but we all saw it i can't clip it i can't clip this
on myself oh i fucking saw it no don't see that heavenly got
that virginia data data center ping that's crazy i love
being on the east oh my god i do oh my god yeah i got zero
on the other servers i had like 23 ping now i have 92
someone on their team european i think so rosas is he i
thought that was such a disgust
When you get in here, I don't know.
I don't know if certain words you're going to be sick.
You can play a lot, please.
I'm going to throw a motion.
Motion sensor?
I used to.
All right.
Here we go.
Gooper so mad.
You're safe.
Oh, they're all over here.
I'm running.
Oh, I'm a corner check.
Yeah, I knew there's someone there.
Oh, he was right.
I had a feeling.
Oh, there's two there.
There's two there.
Yeah, I was going to say, wait a second so I can make that.
Oh, there was two on our X.
Oh, and we dropped the bomb.
I called gang.
Yeah.
the bomb that's why i rushed in it's okay oh my god i fucked
up huge motion i got one and then i got crossfired by
someone else oh my god he's so low oh my god oh my god we
shot from the side oh my god my gun was empty okay okay so
there's two people one hp two one is two people i got my one
a super easy 1v3 i got my one
Dude, that's what it's okay.
Three unanswered wins.
Three unanswered wins right here is actually quite big.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is where we do a reverse sweep, right?
Give me the girl with the big machine.
Do you want, you want, okay, I'll give it to you.
Yeah, I'll give it to you.
It's time to unleash my bunk right.
I think I'm going to have to do this, though.
What is blue chip track?
All right, so I'm going to clear the corner next time.
She overcomes congenital blindness.
The chick is blind.
What?
why are we giving the blind girl oh and he's gone oh no run
oh he's back hopefully tomorrow we can ask them to move the
discord server west i'm gonna play be who has the bomb go
miss you have the bomb i do i'm gonna play the the russian
character all right this is it this is where we reverse
sweep i believe i got them stimmies the stimmies for the
entry hey just don't die and make sure you kill somebody
before you go down get your one i'll get my one yeah don't
worry i have the blue zone grenade i've done a lot of damage
this match oh me too oh yeah oh yeah he has i've done
nothing oh there's a there's a there's a thing there you
can't shoot it i didn't get there you i shot it okay i'm
waiting the stim you guys by the way do i just go in We
could motion it.
Where's the motion?
You just set him down outside like this.
No, you can set it inside.
You can throw it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
Wait, wait, wait.
Sim.
Go.
He's right here.
He's in the corner.
Oh, wait.
We're sorry.
Oh.
Dammit wide.
Damn, there's a bunch in that corner.
I think I should have.
I should have definitely threw my blue zone.
She forgot too.
You got the boat.
They're both down.
There's a third one.
There's a third one in this room.
Headhasa.
Holy shit.
They double barrel.
They shot again, bro.
It's just too strong.
Yeah, I think I might have should have just thrown my blue
zone grenade.
I think.
I believe in the surefire clutch.
One minute remaining.
I will donate you $100 if you clutch this.
I don't die.
wait now that i know you just had to zoom in this is
fantastic
what if you're behind you that's that fucking life isn't it
oh oh oh it is 30 seconds remaining i think they're camping
the bomb i don't think i can yeah oh oh they're behind you
behind me there there's nothing i can do oh that was gonna
dry well i got three kills there and one that's crazy yeah
that one i kind of rolled i'm ignored what cheats guys
cheats i can't wait to do this all over again wait guys i
did 1.2 k damage that man oh yeah oh that you carry wait so
then you look see you don't miss isn't well now that i know
you just have to zoom in wait what do you mean is there like
a zoom in option if you mount what wheel up you focus oh so
steady it so you weren't holding your breath when you were
shooting no i stopped the line oh so that's why you were
missing now that you zoom in you don't never miss oh your
chat can never say you're coping you actually found out the
real strat oh no one well now we're seeing you guys tomorrow
yeah i'll see you guys tomorrow three p.m pst guys tomorrow
what's that cst 3 p.m pst no no 3 p.m pst that is 5 p.m p.m
that is 5 p.m okay 5 p.m 5 p.m sure for wait 3 p.m pst pst
pacific time so that would be wake up at 3 5 that would be 5
p.m cst and then 6 p.m est yeah i know i'll be here okay 3 p
.m so same time as yesterday okay yeah same time that's very
convenient tgs guys it was fun playing with you guys today
i'll see you guys tomorrow okay we're playing against this
team most likely bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye bye bye was
fun that was really fun guys uh if you guys want to check
out the get thank you again for pubg blind spot for the
sponsor we're gonna be back on day two um i need to make a
thumbnail for that but we guys enjoyed watching so far if
you guys want to support the stream the sponsor please feel
free to scan the qr code uh click on the link pin in the
chat or in the description below below yeah um definitely a
very silly silly uh very fun silly game uh You have a good
squad to run it with.
Like I said, you guys can see.
We were, I think we were definitely the most chaotic team.
I'm pretty sure the other teams were very, very much more
serious than our team.
The amount of team kills that we had as a team.
I think we had more team.
Honestly, I'm pretty sure we had the most team kills out of
any team.
I don't even think any other team had team kills compared to
us.
Anyway, I hope you guys enjoyed today's stream, guys.
Tomorrow, we're going to be back same time, 3 p.m.
PST.
So, I hope to see you guys there.
Anyways, thank you again for watching, everybody.
As always, everyone, stay hydrated, posture checked.
Yeah, we're going to move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me, head to bed, guys, you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys tomorrow.
Bye, everyone.
Bye, bye.
Thank you.